Hello, hello, oh my god.
Did you guys see the new Overwatch news?
I, I, yes, Overwatch.
By the way, big update in the Overwatch community, in the
FPS community, but they finally decided to call Overwatch 2
Overwatch.
They dropped the deal.
We're like, we're gonna move forward into this new
generation.
of Overwatch.
And then they like went backwards.
They just dropped the two.
Because now it's just no longer called Overwatch 2.
It's now back to Overwatch.
Yeah.
That's like crazy.
We're like, we're gonna move forward.
And then they went backwards.
Like so, so much progress.
Okay.
The craziest thing is that they literally shadow dropped
five new characters.
characters.
I was like, what do we need?
And one of the characters is a fucking cat.
You can play as a cat.
His name is, what is his name again?
I gotta look it up.
Is it just Jetpack cat?
That's literally his name.
Oh my god.
His name is literally Jetpack cat and like it's a cat on a
Jetpack and he's a support character.
He's like, he can play as his fucking name.
It's Davis jetpack cat and he's a cat on a jetpack and like
I don't know what the fuck he's in I guess he's just gonna
be he's on a little drone.
He's literally on a little drone.
He's the he's the marble rivals Jeff.
I can feel it already.
Um Yeah, and then what you could steal your own teammates
and throw them anyway Well, we're gonna be checking out.
Oh, I most likely might try and check out overwatch next
week because There's five new characters that's insane
there's five new characters oh wait is it february 10th okay
the new yeah they're it's all dropping out yeah or the
overwatch rock rocket raccoon um um but yeah it's a cat on a
fucking drone and i don't know how he heals people i
apparently you can kidnap people on the drone and everything
oh my god he's so fat he's literally like garfield shape do
you see him do you see him on this fucking drone when he's
flying around he's literally oh my god this god like i'm
watching the video right now what the fuck is this character
um i don't care about the other four characters they're just
like i don't okay there is like a baddie i will say they
introduced a new baddie what's her name domina bro oh my god
can that shirt get any tighter like is that i'm just like oh
my god like she's not hiding anything um that she's a baddie
baddie uh don't meet bro they they i feel like um because of
rivals they i think like they felt threatened by rivals so
they were like they had to you know they're they're like
slowly shifting into like gooner bait characters because
because they saw how much money marvel rivals was making on
skins alone and yeah see competition is a good thing see
this is uh more sf yay the sfm community it starts rejoicing
um starts celebrating right now and i felt like like seeing
that all the new characters are introducing i felt like
other than not the cat though the cat i mean also the cat i
guess we're like the the jeff bait the jeff slash rocky
raccoon bait um um and it's like it felt like especially
domina domina i can feel that she's gonna get a lot of
gooner bait skins because of like i mean look at her like
when they're gonna when they're gonna make the next um
summer skins i'm pretty sure she's gonna be on the top of
that list that's getting a swimsuit skin i'm like literally
look at her finally finally kyriko's greed will be
vanquished finally um it's called art um I, I mean, wait, I
gotta, wait, where is it?
I'm sorry, the fucking jetpack cat, I fucking, I look at his
face and I'm like, oh my god, it's a cat on a jetpack, and
his name is just jetpack cat, like, there's, like, there's
no funny name, he's literally just jetpack cat, because he's
a cat on a jetpack, like, we don't even get, like, I mean,
that, I guess that is the funny name, but, like, he doesn't
even have, his own name he's just cat on a jetpack um um and
yeah so definitely gonna check out overwatch next week
because i i mean that's so many new characters what um they
they're introducing oh my god domina is a cat tank too oh my
god oh mizuki is a support two supports in this economy wait
they only released one dps wait who's the yeah who's the
fifth character five one two oh wait two dps one tank and
two supports i'm just surprised you know domina domina like
even though it's just one tank it is domina she deserves all
this she deserves the spotlight yeah or actually you can
actually get a entire new rock wait that's literally five
five v five you can literally just like with just all the
new characters actually um anyway what else did i want to
talk about oh yes other than that apparently there was like
a whole like overwatch huge overwatch update called like
over i don't know overwatch spotlight overwatch spotlight
and another thing they announced which i was i couldn't
believe it i was like what the fuck when i saw it was that
uh they announced the san rio overwatch collab so um over
there's gonna be said I I am very surprised because the
whole you know this game is about beating up people so like
I was very surprised that Sanrio agreed to the collab
because like you're killing people so you're you're fucking
killing people so like it doesn't seem very Sanrio like so I
was very surprised that they actually um they actually
agreed like it just doesn't seem like a collab that they
would they would agree on because you don't really get i
don't know i've never seen san rio do collabs with like
games like this it's such a wild combination um but like i i
just i'm like oh my god i get to kill halloweenie like Like,
just like that.
Like, I'm like, I get to, I get to kill Hello Kitty.
Like, um, um, anyway, all these new characters just for them
to only give mercy and Kierkegaard skins.
Golden, thank yous for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're like, goodbye, Hello Kitty.
Pop, pop.
Like, ask Cassidy.
Like, um, um.
I'm not surprised with the I'm not surprised who gets what I
saw people were like be like why it didn't may gets in the
morrow but I'm just like bro it's Kiriko it's Kiriko I what
do you think it's Kiriko like she she's gonna get the top
die um like rank one and two of course it's gonna go to
mercy and Kiriko they're the rank one and two for skin over
watch skins um I'm like you privilege we should all be
thankful that Lucio can even get anything because he
basically he was the token frog so like if he didn't get
because he's so lucky that Kurope is such a popular San Rio
character that Lucio can even get anything apparently there
was a there was a um there was a um overwatch you know like
the votes for for those who don't know in overwatch they do
a vote system for who gets what skin um and like what skin
gets released next and overwatch had like one of the
categories was like street art or like street skate slash
skating and then lucio wasn't included you know who was
included mercy and kiriko um and people were like why the
fuck that lucio not even get like a street slash skating
themed outfit when he literally is like in this like part of
the streets and also is on rollerblades already like there's
no way like how like wait let me see let me see if i can
pull it off like pull up this uh the outfit um it's
literally his thing and he's not even included in the skins
overwatch new skin vote i saw people were complaining about
so that's why i was just like bro where you should be
thankful that lucio is even included in this collaboration
because thank god kurope is a very popular character in san
rio so at least he gets one at least he gets at least we are
so lucky thank god thank god there's only one frog character
Yeah, skin must not sell.
It's not that it doesn't sell.
It's just that Kiriko and Mercy sells the most.
And also, it's because there's a lot of Kiriko one tricks
and a lot of Mercy one tricks and a lot of Widow one tricks.
So all three of them sells the most skins because of it.
Because they also have the most disposable income.
They just sell way too well.
So there's no point in, like, having, uh, there's no point
in, like, having skins on characters that don't sell well.
Oh, yeah, is it this one?
All right, here we go.
Oh, my God.
Um, let me see if I can find it.
Oh, wait, it wasn't, it wasn't Mercy and Kierkegaard, it was
Mercy.
Oh, and also Junkrat, too.
It's actually surprising how many skins, because there's so
many Junkrat One Trick as well that have disposed.
Of course, of course, the Junkrat One Trick players are the
ones that have disposed.
about income they don't care about anything they don't care
about the theme they just want to play explodey boy um it's
it's he's just what they just care about explodey boy anyway
so so this was the one and they were like why isn't lucy all
included in here so um so that's why people were like, why
the fuck isn't Lucio included in this batch of skins?
Because they're like, it's literally like Lucio Core.
Yeah, and then they're like, why?
Why is Juggrat in there?
Because they have more money than Lucio players.
That's why there's more Juggrat 1 tricks than there are
Lucio 1 tricks in this world.
Life's just unfair.
Like, too much Lucio Core to include.
lucio they'll just have an overdose of lucio anyway so
that's oh yeah let me show you guys the other skin uh the
standard that i was so surprising i swear it was like every
time i thought i could get away they he always knows how to
pull me back in but this time it'll be different i was told
he's changed guys guys he's changed he he dropped the two
he's back to his old self guys you don't understand he's
different now like to keep no the toxic abusive relationship
no he's different now he dropped the two he's like he's back
to what he made me fall in love with him in the first place
guys he's just overwatch now just like the good old days
guys just like the honeymoon period he's he's overwatch
again He's different now every get one You don't understand
You don't see him like how I used to see him
He's back to his roots guys You don't understand
I swear I swear it'll be different I swear like yes he has
hurt me many times and yes I always come crawling back but
this time it's different guys this time he has he has a
Sanrio collab guys look look at the shiny new thing guys
Sanrio there's a cat on a jetpack guys look he got a new cat
and he's so he's changed he said he has changed and he's
right he got a new cat and it's on a jetpack
toky don't go back to him toky i've heard those lines before
all right anyway guys under the net that's really all i
wanted to talk about because apparently it was like a
fucking huge it is a pretty big thing like they literally
shadow drawn five new characters and also a sanrio collab so
like um i am so i am excited to check out what actually has
changed oh yeah apparently the ui is different now too um
the the ui is different now so i i personally don't like the
new ui because it reminds me of like a gotcha game it's
fucking weird it on it looks like a gotcha game ui and i'm i
don't know if i with that i like the original ui i don't see
why they have to change it i'll show you guys and i
personally like the original ui so i think it's weird that
they they change the entire thing like but it to me it just
looks like a a gotcha game or like uh i mean it is free to
play um oh my god remember when but oh it's like gotcha
slash fortnite ish so like here's here's what it looks like
on the main page so because like you know like the the down
the tabs at the bottom oh my god hello kitty and friends i
still blows my mind that san rio has an official collab with
uh with overwatch it just feels like oh my god i'm gonna
shoot hello kitty like it's just i don't it just feels so
wrong it feels so wrong i'm gonna shoot halakitti and his
friends like shale thank you thank you for the gifted ship
thank you thank you lali thank you the super chat thank you
thank you um is he gonna refund you for scam you by selling
a sequel game with a promise of single player story and then
banning the idea to sell skins thank you the super chat lali
thank you thank you look he's different now okay he might
have done all of that but i forgive him because he got a new
cat and It's on a jetpack.
Cheryl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Patra, Sue, thank you for the super chat.
Sanrio, please collab with Call of Duty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He got the cat for me, guys.
That's all it takes.
And he's on a jetpack.
might I repeat it is on a jetpack and it is a support
character he did that for me I know he did I it's not for
the what he did he purposely introduced that character for
me
um anyway let's play God of War it has been uh two weeks
since we last played God of War but I so i do remember this
story um and um and the country surprisingly i actually
remember the controls and stories this time um even though
it has been two weeks uh we sort of did play a lot of rivals
the last two weeks because of all the fucking tournaments
but it's okay now i'm it's okay i'm i'm okay now um guys
it's okay guys uh i'm i've i've got better guys i haven't
booted up rivals the last two days i got my rivals fixed
because next week we're going to be booting up overwatch
yeah we're going back to our first love we're going back uh
let me see 6.3 i gotta adjust the sound real quick yeah a
whole two days like baby steps guys baby steps i'm gonna get
my 10 what was it the 10 day chip I didn't relapse back to I
didn't relapse yet guys it's all about the baby yeah I got
I've been sober for two days guys I'm gonna get my three-day
chip tomorrow and then 10-day chip later next week I'm
reformed all right let's see I think I got the sound done
booting up God of War I should call her yeah yeah it's been
I mean like I haven't talked to her in a long time do you
You think he misses me, guys?
I should really call Overwatch right now.
Cheryl, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you, crazy.
You think he's thinking about me right now?
You know, like, oh, we've been together for so long.
It's like on and off, you know, but we always get back
together in the end, guys.
Like, you know, we always do somehow always get back
together in the end.
And, you think, and he's like, you know, he's different now,
you know, he has, he has a cat, guys, he has a cat on a jet
pack.
And, you know, he's back to his old whimsy self, you know,
when we used to say being like, oh, man, why don't you have
fun characters like Winchton, you know, a giant gorilla, you
know, giant talking gorilla.
And then they kept making like more humans and stuff.
And we're like, there's no more whimsy anymore.
There's more excitement in your, in your character creations
and stuff like that.
And then he introduced Brig, like Brigette, Brig G, oh my
God, I forgot her, Brig, you know, and then it all went
downhill when she, he introduced Brig.
And then I, we were like, there's no more whimsy anymore,
you know, and, and then, and now look, he's back to his old
self again, what made us fell in love in the first place,
guys.
pack and also i mean he did introduce like the most fucking
gooner bait uh character in over and watch that i've ever
seen i don't think we've ever the the the only character
that was ever like to that level was widow maker but even
then domina holy like like oh my god like um like as we've
ever got to what the uh don't domina is is widow maker but
even then like widow i'm sorry but widow maker does not has
like nothing on domina like oh my god that is the most
gooner bait character i've even i've ever seen and like i
played marvel rivals
of war don't worry god of war we have a new game for you to
we have we have a new game for you to sit on a chair for all
right here we go bring back og orissa bro no one wants to
see og orissa the sitting in the fucking corner with the
shield like no get that shit out of here that shit was
cancer to play against i do not want to see og orissa back
at all uh yeah bad whoever said bring back og orissa bro you
love that shit because you were part of the problem you were
part of the problem how did a traveler come to find just
just bring back ghosts at this point when you found me the
truth i pledged my life to it was a lie Lord Freyer, put
what was left of me back together.
Give me something real to believe in.
I don't want to shoot, sit there for 20 minutes to shoot at
Orissa Shields.
You know what that's part?
And then they shoot the shield up into the sky so they can
reset the fucking shield in the corner instantly.
He's lucky to have you.
Just bring back double shield meta at this point.
Just bring back goats.
that ghost and we're gonna bring back all the fucking most
cancer cops tell me about the camp dog oh my god look at him
found her half dead oh she probably escaped the blohunder
breeding farm north of here we all told him she was beyond
saving but he never gave up she healed oh and hasn't left us
since she's a sweet girl she's pure she's so fat goodness
even if you don't oh my god she's like a little like a
little pig dog oh my god wait is this laggy for anybody or
is it just me like I hope it's not laggy for people could
just be me
alright alright seems okay okay so it's just OBS tinkering
up and down the river delta.
Once Odin's army came to town, I led out of there faster
than a tassel worm with its bottom ablaze.
So frazzled, I accidentally left behind a few
irreplaceables.
What?
Irreplaceables.
Yeah.
Well, just one.
Really?
An orb.
I'd be mighty grateful if you would find it.
Ooh, what do I get?
I didn't come across any of my old beautifully rusted armor
pieces.
I'll use the scrap to whip up something special suited just
for you okay is it worth it guys just bring it back there is
it is it is it actually give me a better armor is it worth
it do i retrieve the orb keep an eye out for my old armor
i'll fix it up for you free charge yeah what sort of orb do
you imagine we're looking for brother i do not know all
right we gotta find the orb up to you okay if it if it's an
actual all right let's see if i have anything i need to
change anywhere no um just want to make sure oh this is new
throw a that swerves into a gantz a bonus to melee damage
for a short duration throw a bifrost to and try that know
we'll try that fuck it might as well oh i could upgrade it
again yeah fuck it let's try that spider in range oh i
accidentally used it up on up on that relic that doesn't
fuck me over wait high risk staying mobile and charging up
oh 55 defense though oh that's a lot of defense uh not lost
core thank you the super chat thank you thank you hey dokey
it's my birthday today i may be sick but your streams and
the dragoons have always cheered me up and helped me pass
the time happy birthday we have a great birthday happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear
lost core happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday yeah All
right, let's see.
What else do I want to...
Ooh, wait.
Luck chance grants a blessing of cooldown when interrupting
double blue ring attacks.
Or parrying.
Oh, okay.
I've been parrying a lot, so that should be good.
I don't know.
It is level four.
Okay, double tap the shield bash for stun.
It's a shield fit for staying mobile and charging up.
I guess we're like double taps, right?
it charge up blocking attack deplete some charge shield
punch right before an attack hits you to absorb it and gain
a burst of damage all right we'll try that up because it
does say 55 defense and i like it when numbers go up when
numbers go up some it means good right elios flash holy shit
okay guys i know i say i remember how to play this game but
i think i i'm like thinking about it i was like do i
actually remember how to play this game i'm like thinking
now i'm like i think i actually remember i'm i'm sort of
like thinking now and i'm like i don't i don't think i
actually remember guys
All right, let's see.
Wait, what's this?
What?
I can have...
Oh!
Damage!
Wait, stun.
Yeah!
Wait.
I like damage.
Damage!
More damage!
All right.
Number go big means...
Oh, is it this?
Undiscovered.
Wait, why is it undiscovered?
undiscovered.
Is that where the orb is?
Is this where the orb is, guys?
Is that why it's undiscovered?
More damage means more power.
Number go up.
Doki happy.
Hey.
Hello.
I'm glad it worked.
Whatever you help to do out there.
I'm still not sure I totally get you or what your deal is,
but As long as you have her back I'll have yours.
Yeah, that's right future brother-in-law.
I'm gonna fuck your sister What's rude about asking for help
big fear my love focus on your work You need to weave those
tighter Hello, hey guys, what are you guys talking about
your alliance is unusual I think what Kratos is trying to
say is he's never seen a light health and dark health work
together.
He's like, yeah, right.
Amir tells me you're something of an adventurer.
Should you ever find your way to the forbidden sands and
Alphine?
Contested territory.
Pass the barons.
There are rumors of a sanctum and artifacts our elders don't
want us to see.
Anything that sheds light on our suppressed history would
benefit all of Alphine.
Uncovering secret history?
Sounds like my kind of adventure.
together stories of alfheim before the division of light and
dark it's very taboo didn't stop you from spreading word of
it oh how you ended up in prison where she and I met as
enemies naturally but escaped as friends and now more than
friends oh
I miss the light do you the truth I still feel its pull you
want nothing else when you're near it it's so forbidden
you're only biting time until you can drink again from the
light but then again the light does not make good food it
doesn't play music or tell jokes or open your eyes to new
things it makes you run in place.
The more I am away from it, the more I see it for what it
really is.
What is it?
And I don't need it anymore.
Oh my god, he's doing it.
He's sober.
He's sober now.
He doesn't need the light drug.
Is someone going to ask me if I miss Oh, I'm sorry, man.
Of course.
How rude of me.
In their defense, love.
You are usually not the most talkative.
He's like, now that I have a hot A hot, dark elf girlfriend?
I don't need no light.
The elders say it is why we fight.
But all of that...
It's shit.
I am more than the high.
More than a soldier.
Light elves, dark elves.
Damn, she's a strong independent woman.
Stubborn, brainless as moths blinded by their light.
So true, sister.
the shadows and there I found my people yeah I would stop
smoking for my for my girlfriend too for my hot goth
girlfriend you can go away thank you for sharing when the
baddie is so bad she cures your drug addiction she fixed him
always nice to meet a fellow scholar she did it and Kratos I
understand your Oh my god, wait, he's still talking.
When things quiet down, I'd love to hear their ideas and
your own.
I have nothing to say that will interest you.
Nonsense, brother.
I've heard many a wise word past those sunburned lips.
It's all right, Mavir.
My wife is much the same way.
Careful.
Wife?
It's not even girlfriend no more.
She loves me so much.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it he scored he made it guys he actually
made it he actually did it guys he's the dream he's the end
goal no why he made the grants the cop wife achieved all
right came over here I want to know more about his their
relationship there's actual where the fuck is the orb guys i
don't there's there's nothing on my map about the orb do i
have to explore no not exploring oh it's here i didn't sorry
gamers don't look down apparently the mysterious orb never i
found it sorry i didn't realize there was a bottom path of
the map of course i remember where to look for a gateway
gamers don't look up or down left or right we look forward i
hope this alliance has some staying power after all it seems
to me we share a common enemy kratos you may not accept that
ragnarok is inevitable but you're smart enough to know odin
is a threat whatever comes i mean yeah it does seem like a
pre-clear it looks like a mob boss do you agree i do then as
to brock's offer you can imagine staying under the same roof
as a couple former enemies no further temptations towards
terrible vengeance oh hey i got xp for just walking either
of you nice you have my word all right raeus unlock new
combat element equipment and unique skill tree her use of
both sonic and sigil arrows opens new options in combat and
puzzles wait what's the point of having a son then she's
stronger all right freya summons provide critical aid in
combat and can be activated by holding 12 oh sorry 12 square
12 I don't know where 12 came from but it can be activated
by holding square runic summons take time to recharge what
the fuck okay 12 yeah holding 12 guys we don't need a son no
more i can make a new son all right
armor finding equipped different armor she also benefits
from shared assist accessory digest common styles for her
and our traias press l to your skills jesus christ oh she
has more stuff upgrade her new stuff all right we'll get one
from each enters her valkyrie form holy shit arceus why
can't you do that much more aggressive oh my god wait she's
pretty cool all right well all right let's see uh sonic
mid-attacks okay we'll grab that emmy's killed it can deal
uh using refunds and runic arrow silent deals greatly
increased okay we'll grab that and then that we'll get some
more stun shit deals increased damage all right we'll grab
all of these and then armor oh this is just ascetic okay uh
oh which frog i like i like her original.
I think her original is really cute.
Yeah, but can he, can she turn into a furry?
Oh.
Yeah, full-grown goddess versus losers, son.
Let's see.
Actually, I'll get the original armor is really cute, but
But then I get to see her neck in the song.
I get to see her beautiful neck.
Alright, let's sort.
Okay, Toki.
I get to see her lovely personality more in this outfit,
guys.
Wait, is that a dress?
Okay, what is the other armor?
Okay, wait.
I want to see what does it look like with this.
Oh, but then, like, the dress covers the back more.
Wait, sorry, we're getting a little fashion show with my new
wife.
I can't see her legs, though.
Her personality.
Sorry, I can't see her personality more.
Give me a sec.
Sorry, Freya.
Just give me a sec.
I just gotta know which armor shows your personality more to
me.
Yeah, I think I like her original.
Her original is better.
Her original makes her personality shine a lot.
You'll need an enchantment on your chisel to use it.
How do I do that?
Oh, oh my god.
That's easy.
The letter I.
That's it.
It's just...
It's an incantation.
I'll speak it.
Look at that!
We're doing it!
Is he always making puns like that?
Yeah, I got used to it Okay, how do I locked by more vines?
Remember what to do?
Actually, I don't It's been two weeks, ladies It's been...
Oh my god, it was like...
Oh, yeah, it was that!
Okay, and then...
It's actually been two weeks.
I've actually...
Um...
What the fuck do I do?
It's been so long.
Oh.
Oh, wait, here.
Um.
Give me a sec.
I wonder where the control is again.
Oh, it's here.
It's here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, yeah.
I figured it out.
Wait.
Oh, right, one.
Oh, here we go.
All right.
And then, boom!
What?
Oh, shit.
I fucked it up.
Okay, one, two, three.
Boom!
There we go.
See, exactly.
See, I told you guys.
It's like riding a bicycle.
It has something on it I don't recognize.
All right.
And then we...
There you go.
We did it.
See, guys, it's like riding a bicycle.
Okay, look, it's called Ping, okay?
There's 500 MMS right now to my brain.
It's 1230 p.m.
Ship shape.
He sleeps in a broom closet now.
But he's adjusting.
How did you find him?
Largely, that's down to Atreus, having figured out how to
access the prophecies giants reserved for their own kind.
We only learned of it ourselves after Thor and Odin came
calling.
To your home?
Is it still standing?
Barely.
But all the violence was seemingly just a distraction to let
Odin have a private one with Atreus.
Odin was alone with your son?
Did he tell you what they spoke of?
Yes.
He said that Odin invited him to Asgard.
Oh my gosh.
It's like a little family meeting.
He's rushing into Faden's searcher.
That's troubling.
He gets to meet the family.
I guess to go to Asgard.
God, what's so troubling about that?
If you're ready to talk to him, the Mystic Gateway is ahead.
If not, I have some unfinished business up this river I
could use your help with.
Wait, what's ahead?
I'm right, there's so many choices.
If you want to continue exploring, we'll need to remove that
log in the river.
Alright, we got this.
Ooh, loot!
Wait, what's this?
What is this?
The crest of Skirnear, never quite as smart as he thought.
Oh, nice.
Loot.
I love loot.
More loot!
Alright, so...
Wait, was this something special?
No, it's just a random pot.
Alright, let's destroy this real quick.
Alright, we got five in the orb.
Oh, yay!
More loot!
I love loot!
Yeah, quick side question.
10 minutes in and out.
Surely it'll be okay, right?
Not necessarily, but good.
I mean, she's going to be stronger.
That's always a plus.
I left something behind near the falls.
Your wedding sign.
Now, why do you want to be going back there?
To be free of the bonds of my marriage.
What the fuck is that?
I think you severed that a long time ago.
Not completely.
Oh, it's a big John Pig.
Guide us.
What else would she...
How else would she be connected?
Favors.
I assume...
Am I going to reach the entrance of Faria's wedding?
Alright, where...
How far is it?
How far is it compared to the orb?
Okay.
That one...
Okay, alright.
So it's just...
It's on the path.
Where am I, actually?
Wait a minute.
What's this?
Faria's cap?
Okay, I'm right here.
Alright.
Oh, that's cute.
The wildlife here is really cute.
Oh my god.
Look, it's a monkey!
Shoot it.
All right.
Oh my god, there's... Oh, okay.
There's my people.
There's a crow here.
Many ages ago.
Thousands traveled it on pilgrimage to the shrine of
worship.
But then the Asir came.
I'll go.
I'm already lost.
The wilds reclaimed it.
It was beautiful ones.
Alright.
That seems like a friendly animal.
Hello, are you okay?
Hello?
Oh, not friendly!
Not friendly!
Oh my god, it's not a pig!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I don't remember how to play this game.
It's not...
Guys, it wasn't a fucking...
I thought it was a friendly giant pig.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I don't remember how to play.
I actually don't remember how to play this game.
Oh, this is so bad.
This is so bad.
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
Okay, I don't know how to throw.
Oh, shit.
Get buried.
That's fucking right.
Where's my?
Where's my axe?
Where is it?
Oh, my God.
Just.
Press all the buttons!
Surely something is right!
Alright, he's down.
Oh my god!
Oh shit, okay!
Alright, do your thing!
Do your thing!
Okay, he's no longer evil.
I mean, he's still evil, but he's no longer evil, evil.
Oh, okay.
Everything's fine.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's okay.
Things are fine right now.
Oh, okay.
It's okay.
Wait, wait.
I'll use...
Yeah, that's fucking right.
Okay.
Oh my god, he just fucking flicks it away.
That's cheating.
No!
Oh shit!
I'm trying to remember how to switch weapons!
Oh!
No!
Okay, okay, it's okay.
We did it.
It's so...
This game is so easy, guys.
I...
So easy.
Not even close.
Okay, um, let me try to remember how to swap weapons.
Okay, this is sheaving the weapon.
Okay, left, right.
Okay, this is how I swap weapons.
All right, I figured it out.
Only took one fight.
Another quest?
Why does everyone want me to do their errands?
Spirit.
You return.
Astrid.
happened to you to your garden the angry are my life's work
rotted the quest woman in the quest glory reduced to this i
am sorry my queen you need never apologize to me like just a
little eric boy to keep this garden in bloom until you
return to live forever amongst its peak treason's
return astrid kratos we purge this garden of poison oh yeah
i mean that'd be nice garden for the dead the earth is a
reflection of those who tended i mean it'd be nice if it's
not poison her soul will be as well how do i do that this is
how like where am i oh glad to see that still works
I mean, I'm not purging the garden, but I get free stuff at
least.
Yay!
Why do I purge this?
You suspicious of her, brother?
If the orb she seeks is important, she would not have left
it behind.
Where is the poisonous dance?
Yeah?
They're poisoning Astrid's garden.
Oh, here!
Oh!
Well, I need to figure out how to shoot that.
Oh, here you go.
Shoot it here.
No, right here.
Oh, wait.
And then...
Boop!
Oh!
Oh, okay.
That's awkward.
Um...
Uh...
Okay, wait, wait.
I get it.
And then...
Boop!
There we go.
That I figured it out.
Okay.
And then...
Yeah, but where do I sit over here?
From a different angle.
I mean, yeah, that works.
If it works, it works.
Oh, I gotta read real quick.
This mentions a spell that puts trolls to sleep.
And a magic relic that acts as a sort of counter spell.
Alright, where is the last fire?
I mean...
No?
How do I get there?
It's like in there.
I don't know how to reach that pot.
This pot might be harder to reach.
Yeah, attacks failed successfully.
Oh, there it is.
How?
It's like all the way up here.
How the fuck do I reach that?
Purple arrow.
Oh, yeah!
I forgot.
It's like that.
Sigil arrows won't work on this.
Why not?
Oh, my God.
The way for it.
Recharge.
Oh, my God.
This is... Okay.
I'm trying to figure out where to aim this at.
Maybe here?
No?
Or here?
There you go.
That should work.
Okay, maybe not.
Maybe.
Oh my god!
And he shoots me too!
Go up and around?
Maybe, like, here.
Alright, here we go.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you...
Oh!
Okay, all right.
Don't worry.
I figured this out, guys.
It's so easy.
There you go.
What?
You're totally fucking connected.
What do you mean?
Oh, my God.
Where else would you be connected to?
I await the day when my garden closes again.
I'm so good.
I'm confused.
Behind me?
What's behind me?
Just a dead lady.
I have to find the core.
Where the fuck is this core?
There's nothing else connected to it.
Of the opposite building?
I can get on top of it?
That's an option?
I'm just like...
What do you mean?
I'm just as confused as you, Kratos.
Don't worry.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Do this real quick and look around.
Maybe he's like around here.
Like hidden in the...
In the poison.
You know?
Can I not do it from here?
Or do I just have to leave this area?
finally oh my god you're actually legally not allowed to
kill the monkey like it's like some endangered species shit
he's like on the list i'm legally not allowed to shoot the
monkey he's a protected he's a protected species all right
there's this though
this building what building am i looking at this one not
this building i'm so confused my garden is still is dead i'm
sorry i'm trying you're just sitting there oh when i broke
the pods yeah but how do i get in there you're literally all
you're doing is moping moping doesn't help anybody I'm
trying my best, lady.
What are you doing?
You're just dead.
Like, what is your purpose?
I want to grab that, but I don't know how.
Oh, wow, Doki.
You're just gonna victim blame now.
Look, I am trying my best to help her out, but if she's just
gonna sit all day moping about it, it ain't gonna solve
anything.
Freya, something your brother said.
The Ace here burned him.
We weren't yet at war, but relations with the Vanir and Ace
here had been hostile for ages.
Freya got it into his head that he could improve relations
by sharing our magic with them.
How the fuck do I do this?
Vanir techniques for bountiful harvests.
Enough to feed their whole...
population getting set on fire was the thanks he got that's
true the acer were too undisciplined and impatient for the
subtlety of vanier spellcraft so when things went wrong they
blamed their teacher ah but enough of that for now all right
left wall for closed door what wait okay so like for that
puzzle is it like Is like the answer like in the area or
what?
Or do I have to like go somewhere else?
Like for this, for the answer to this puzzle.
Like is the answer here in the area or is it actually
somewhere else?
Just right of the poison.
Oh my god there was a fucking course of course there were.
Of course there's always a hidden passage.
A fucking course there was a hidden area.
Alright, there it is.
That has to be the route.
Yeah.
There we go.
Learn anything?
Alright, nice.
And then...
Ringo!
Yay!
I did it.
I solved the puzzle, guys.
It was in the corner.
Look, it's been two weeks.
Guys, it's been two weeks, guys.
It's been so long.
Oh my god, it blooms.
Does that mean there's a hidden area here, too?
Look.
The door's held shut by that counterweight.
We lower it.
The door will open.
The counterweight?
What
do you mean by counterweight?
Wait.
Oh!
That counterweight.
How do I get that?
Okay, wait.
Uh...
Can I reach that?
I don't think so.
Huh?
I don't think I can reach that eye.
I don't know if I can reach that eye.
Maybe we could get closer from the other side.
Yeah, but then I'm on a boat and apparently I can't do shit
on the boat.
Like...
But I'm on the boat, like I'm not allowed to touch anything.
They're growing from that bridge.
I guess I have to be like over there on that bridge to do
anything.
Alright, let's go climb up that wall again.
I'm pretty sure I have to throw my axe up there.
Guys, it might have been a bad decision to wait two weeks.
Just maybe.
Okay.
There we go.
I fixed your stupid garden.
Let's return to Astrid.
Alright.
Your garden is fixed now.
You can go see the light.
Go across the light.
Yes.
Oh!
It's time to move on.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, in front of me?
Wow.
What did I get out of it?
A temporary one.
The garden will die again.
Yeah, but she won't know.
That is no reason not to try.
Yeah, but she won't know that it's gonna die.
All right, let's go this way.
When I go find the orb, the orb is very important.
It's this way.
Following the compass?
Because I can follow directions.
We're close.
There should be a gate up ahead.
That's quite a gate.
Don't suppose you know a way through.
A pilgrim gate.
I can open it.
We just need to find the right vantage point.
is this not good enough like okay uh what is considered the
right vantage what does she mean by that like so flair was a
guest when odin burned him not exactly that's not romantic
enough he saw the potential of the magic and wanted to know
more than how to improve crop yields It was a mob of lesser
Aesir, bitter and short-sighted, who tied him up and lit him
a flame.
Oh, up here!
Okay, I see it.
I see it.
Obviously, he survived.
In fact, he used the opportunity to escape.
But such an affront made war inevitable.
Freyr certainly wasn't the same after that.
At least for a while.
His carefree ways were replaced with nightmares, paranoia,
and lies.
lashing out it doesn't excuse what he said at my wedding but
i do understand where his anger came from all right let us
go read a little bit here before we go back to our quest
multiple upgrades are available what do those fancy words
say all right let's see if there's anything oh oh nice i can
upgrade my axe that's actually pretty good for free and
whatnot um what am i what am i equipped on oh wait that's
level four oh level four is better than level three oh but
this has 18 on it you know what i'm gonna craft this 18 is
better than uh oh equip please 11 and i can upgrade this too
Kratos so offended that Odin burned Freya because he and
Greeks highly vile hospitality.
He even let Thor and Odin into his home because they asked
politely and brought a gift.
Oh, that makes sense.
Look, he is a murderer, but he's a very polite murderer.
A banana.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look.
Manners still exist.
You still owe me the story of who made these things.
Okay, what do I have equipped right now?
Actually, what even did I make?
Okay, I had to cast a castive blow at the end of the R1
combo.
Okay, I love the R1 combo.
Oh, I have this equipped.
Okay, I'll upgrade this right now since I have it.
I'll put some hurt on them.
Alright, any better armor?
Oh,
Wait, level 5?
For this arm, I'm going to get better armor, right?
With the orb?
Is it better than this, chat?
Is the armor better than the lost Kuras or Suras?
I'll make this one too.
Oh, it's free?
Oh, I don't even have...
Never mind.
I don't even have the equipment.
I don't even.
Oh, I have the belt.
I do have the belt, though.
Okay, we'll craft the belt.
It's level five.
Alright.
Grab the belt.
Unfortunately, don't have the bracers or whatever the fuck
that was.
I mean...
Enchantments.
Oh my god.
There's so many stuff I can do now.
Oh, my head hurts.
It's like, there's too many things I can do.
An enchantment with Misty.
Okay, increases melee damage when he's above.
Okay, based on luck.
I'll craft that.
More mass.
All right, how do I equip that then?
Wait.
Wait, how do I equip that?
Where can I put it?
Oh, here.
There we go.
Okay, I figured it out.
Feels like there was something else.
Alright.
Figured...
Oh, shit, wait.
Wait, there's a chest here.
Oh, I don't know where that opens, though.
Alright, we'll go here first.
We'll disembark here for the free stuff.
And I feel like there might be enemies here.
because why are there fire pots in the open?
Oh, there it is.
BAB!
What am I right?
Where?
Oh, here!
That's fucking right.
Ace!
BAB!
I'll get rid of the...
Oh, wait, she's summoning them.
That makes sense.
That should make sense.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
It's okay.
I can I remember I'll play this game Okay, that's not good.
That's not good guys.
Okay, I swear to God I remember I'll play this game Oh, it's
not fair I miss it's okay I swear to God I remember how to
play Behind me are you fucking oh my god I'm one HP Oh my
god!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I swear to God, I won't play this game.
There you go.
I'm just freezer.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm not doing okay right now.
I'm not.
A stupid fucking projection.
down all right there you go now is the easy part oh my god i
forgot i have lock-in all right all right all right i
remember the lock-in move we're doing it okay maybe not that
but we're doing it now look easy easy guys another ghost my
soul cannot rest until they How many fucking ghosts are
here?
Oh, God.
See, baby steps, guys.
Wait, did I not lock?
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
All right, see you guys?
Baby steps.
Is that something?
Why is it glowing?
all right we figure it out how to lock into enemies now how
do we get up there i wonder we can't not with those vines in
the way all right what does this guy want what is wrong i
died no fucking shit what happened to you i don't know i'm
fucking dead we needed a way to fight back i suggested say
that i understand your desperation that was foolish clearly
I was lucky enough to be murdered before my mind could be
corrupted as theirs did you must free them of course say
their magic corrupts so ruthlessly all right do must be an
agony then we shall give them death how the fuck am I gonna
fix her
Whoa!
Fucking...
Oh my god, I forgot about those guys.
God fucking damn it.
I forgot those guys existed.
All right, um...
Does my thing reach it?
God damn it.
What does my thing reach?
Oh.
Does anyone remember what the kid...
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I marched.
I matched it.
Like, how do I reach that?
My thing doesn't go that far.
Oops, whoops.
It's not that long.
It's a very above average size, but it's not that long.
Okay, here.
Here you go.
I can touch that.
All right, this.
Okay, I can touch that.
All right.
There we go.
That should work now.
Are you serious?
Okay, here.
There we go.
I did it.
Look like that worked.
Easy.
Oh, and there's a chest here, too.
So easy.
Yay!
Free money.
All right, I kicked that.
down.
I need to check what's over here.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew it's not just one trap.
It's not it's never just one trap.
It's never one.
I grab this.
way we'll need to find another way around all right that's
fine that's fine that's all right uh got him my friend's
souls are still twisted aren't they give them the friends
like someone like set up a ye old prank you're like can't
wait for in 50 years sucks to be that guy 50 years when he
encounters his prank everything's changed i'm a stranger
Oh, it's time to read.
The runic word appeared over there.
See it?
Oh, yeah.
Alright, it's time to write.
Oh my god.
My new wife is teaching me how to read and write.
I actually love right there.
We should be able to reach the wedding scene.
Nice.
Just teach me how to read and write, guys.
Yeah, why did my son not do that?
Yeah, honestly.
My dead beast son wouldn't even teach me how to read.
Despite his actions in Midgard, Atreus does still care for
you.
I know.
I raised a son too.
It may be hard to believe, but he was quite similar to
Atreus at this age.
Alright, guys, I got it.
He adored his father.
Always wanted to do right by him.
was constantly frustrated that no matter what he did he
never could seem to get his approval he confided in me a lot
sought the comfort his father withheld oh my god it's over
there he has befriended the other dwarf the blue ones
brother oh well if cindry has that covered i suppose there's
no need for me in his life anymore is there that is not what
i mean sarcasm She's like, he chose he chose a dwarf over
her.
I mean, she was trying to kill him, though.
Alright.
So there is red binds over there.
Can I even see that?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Uh.
Can I reach that, though?
I don't think I can, right?
Let's see.
okay where does my okay where does how okay this is so
inconvenient wait it's right here okay never mind i'm so
stupid okay i should really reach that nice okay never mind
all right never mind we're actually gonna have to
Does that hit?
Oh my god.
Where does...
Alright.
We do here.
Here.
And then here.
There you go.
That should work.
How does that not reach it?
The circles were connecting!
Okay.
And then we'll do one here.
That looks like it's connected, right?
They're definitely touching!
Is it not?
Oh, it's not.
Oh, no, it's not.
Okay, and then...
you think they're touching now I can't tell okay oh my god I
got one two but not the three yeah but doesn't it only make
it bigger like three times like that yeah and then if I do
it here yeah see all right here we go Oh, here it is.
Okay, it's still not touched.
God, fucking stupid rock.
All right, that looks like a very big circle.
And then we put one here.
And then one here.
And then it should cut.
Oh, does it look like?
Oh my God, never mind.
It disappeared.
All right, and then...
One, two, three.
There you go.
Made it.
We made it.
That should connect now.
Oh, each rune can get... Okay, it's like... I figured it
out.
I figured it out.
Watch this.
One, two, three.
Now, now it'll touch.
There's no way this doesn't touch.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I figured it out.
One, two, three.
And now, there's no way they don't touch now.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Alright.
One.
two three one two three okay there you go there you go
there's no way there's no way I could literally see them
overlapping each other it's like a fucking Venn diagram oh
my okay wait wait wait one two three one two three okay here
go here go here go all right this is like a triple bin
diagram there's no way why did it not go up what it got okay
wait wait wait wait
one two three okay okay it's touching one two three there
you go there you go there you go three of them yeah yeah
steve no it was too late it expired
one two i think it's touching Oh my god, it's expiring.
The one where I can make it.
Well, let it explode.
Guys, let me let it explode real quick.
One, two, three.
One.
One, two, please.
It's good.
No, it gives a sparring!
God!
She has a cooldown!
Can't go much faster!
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Okay.
That has to touch.
Look, CC, she doesn't care how long it took.
We made it.
She didn't care.
She's like, you know what?
You did the best you could.
I'm like, thank you.
She didn't care.
It's all about the end, not the journey.
It's all about the end result, guys.
She didn't care.
She complimented me, too.
You know, I would have beaten you.
What?
earlier if it's on this yeah
perhaps see guys she complimented me i would rather not i'll
bet you wouldn't all right let's go okay it's this way we
have all right is it this way yeah it is The closer we get,
the more tightness grows in my chest.
I'm in.
See, she doesn't care.
She looks past over my faults.
It must be done.
I've lived with this pain far too long.
If you can believe it, we were happy once.
Really?
Like what?
For like 10 minutes?
Perhaps that was my mistake.
All I wanted was to protect my family.
There is no shame in that.
I failed.
all the same i was like you were happy the sex cannot be
that good lady
for your people were dying must be say they're nearby he's
like i was happy once i was like were you though were you
oh there's the orb we did it We can go now.
Lundas or.
Be cautious.
We know not what it does.
You really think she'd send us again the bloody thing if it
was going to kill us?
Let's just take it back to her.
Alright.
Oh, this.
I don't know how to do this part.
Okay, not that part, though.
Interesting.
Are you serious?
Oh, my God.
Not again.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Wait, how do I read?
that how the fuck okay I know there's this can I even hit
that
okay I got one of them I guess I'll throw this oh wait but I
don't wait it doesn't even burn it
Does it burn this?
No.
Okay, that makes no sense.
How the fuck does that not burn anything?
It's literally a bomb.
Okay, but does that hit the other one, though?
What about this?
Oh, it does hit it.
Okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
Come on.
Alright, there we go.
And then...
One more!
How the fuck did that not burn it?
Did I do it?
What the fuck?
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm cooking.
Wait, can I throw it from here?
Okay.
Not really.
Oh.
I was like, oh, did I do all my turns do i need to like pay
it's like a carnival game okay i actually have to like go up
oh my god how close does it have to be
okay that's three is that three
one two three one
Well, fuck me, I guess.
Oh my, we don't need that.
It's alright, guys.
That item might not be important, anyway.
It's okay.
I think the item is not that important.
There's no way.
The Veiled Passage.
Alright.
I'm pretty sure that item wasn't that important.
important but what what what if it is no no i'm pretty sure
it's all right i'm pretty sure that item wasn't even that
big of a deal no trap this chest just sitting in the open
just like that that's all linda's armor taking care of yeah
i bet that chest was even if was empty or something
but can i destroy that Arrows won't work on this.
This is destroyable, right?
Uh...
No?
Okay.
It's not that.
Uh...
And not Kaboomit?
All right.
Kapoom?
No kapom?
No, okay.
No kapom, I guess.
I don't know how to break that.
Arrow press freeze.
Can I freeze it?
Oh, yay!
Not kapom.
It was kapom.
All right.
See, I can do puzzles.
nice oh my god i saw the trap i saw the trap i saw the trap
i saw the trap i saw the trap i saw i saw all the traps i
saw the traps i went in there we go eva thank you for the
raining thank you oh my god it comes back all right there we
go nice all right up we go yeah
I like instead of yellow paint, it's just...
It's red paint instead.
Red and white paint.
Actually, let me grab this.
Oh, fuck it.
Let's grab the loot now.
Money is money.
Wait, what?
Okay, I'm gonna say, where was the shortcut I made?
Oh, time to read!
Just reading is fundamental.
Anything interesting, brother?
Give me a sec real quick.
Let me double check something real quick.
Boop.
Oh.
I had to check my messages.
Ah, work stuff in behind the scenes.
Over there.
February truly is hell month.
Uh.
Are they friendly?
They were very friendly anymore, do they?
Let us put them to rest.
Alright.
Oh.
Here you go, I did it!
Oh, he's like, what happened to this guy?
He's just like, wait, what happened to him?
That's crazy.
Wait, don't worry, you can't block his feet.
Yeah, I fucking do it.
That's right, get out of here.
Can't block that.
It must have been the win.
He's like, what happened to that guy?
Oh well, not my problem.
It must have been the wind.
Up I go.
We should get moving.
Oh, I see you.
Fool me once.
Shame on me.
Fool me twice.
Maybe shame on me again.
Because I have no pattern recognition.
Oh shit!
Bro, that guy just ran in.
Like, where the fuck did that guy come from?
There we go.
Nice.
I froze him so hard, he disappeared.
What the fuck?
Okay, I have, like...
Are you serious?
Oh, wait, there.
Oh my god, bro, I have fucking poisonous flowers in the way.
What am I supposed to- Okay, I'm just gonna run past
everything.
Like, what the fuck am I supposed to do?
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do.
Oh my god, what are you even- Bro, fucking flower!
Alright, that's fine.
It's fine Oh, yeah, they're dead dead.
Okay, don't come back at least at least they don't come back
God damn flower
All right, that's fine I want to make it so Okay, there you
go Oh shit, I didn't mean to do that I'm trying to like
remember all the combos and stuff up okay how do i fully
wait guys does anyone remember how fully freeze the axe
because i don't is it that you just hold it and does it say
frozen forever no it doesn't there was one a move where you
can make it make your axe freeze forever not forever for
before a little bit you know what i'm
Oh my god, a stupid fucking flower!
Oh my god!
Oh, it's a triangle?
Okay, it was triangle.
Okay, thank you.
I was like, I remember there was a move.
Okay, there we go.
That's what I wanted to know.
A stupid fucking flower.
That's right.
Get blocked.
Oh my god, you can't even kill it!
I don't- where is the mother flower?
Oh my god, it's right here.
That's right.
I found it.
I found that that's right.
Burn!
I don't care if you're a protected species.
Oh wait, I can't fight him now.
There we go.
That's right.
What you're going to do now?
What about your stupid shield?
That's fucking right.
You're invested in the wrong stat!
Alright.
Got my axe back.
Yoko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I survived Mr. Beast Lunchables and all I got was the super
chat and 25 guys.
25 guys named Bob.
Thank you for the super chat.
chat you're good and thank you all right more loot i think
the worst part is that i'm not even doing the main the main
mission it's all just sad for us this isn't even the main
story
what the i blocked that yeah but then she'll be stronger so
be worth it in the wait i'm back here did i finish that
other mission there's so many missions i don't even know
which one is which oh is that the guy from portnite thinking
of the super chat yo they could thank you okay one back here
what was the point of being back here why am i back here Did
I freed them?
Did I do it?
Did I freed all the...
Did I freed her friends?
I've lost track.
There's so many side quests.
Do I do it?
Can you be put to rest now?
Can you move on?
I don't know.
Oh, yes, I did it.
It's done.
I did.
I killed your friends.
And...
I'm sorry.
Okay.
But I've been here.
I would have prevented this.
Do you think us lie?
I didn't blow my nose and capable of making our own choices.
No, but we made a mistake.
But it was ours to make.
Not yours to prevent.
Even if you had been here.
I... Yes, you're right.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, my gods.
Bye-bye.
I did my job.
Kratos.
Yeah?
Thank you for taking the time to help me.
people i help no one okay they're already dead oh but you
did that's true you put their spirits at ease and that has
eased my spirit as well i feel lifted oh my god i'm in it
will not last you're right there are most certainly other
corrupted sisters out in the realms you always know how to
end on a cheery note brother um did i wish that what did i i
wish that grabbing that for us all right here's the orb
oh thank you so much is that a fucking squeaker toy that's
what the orb was what all right oh my god oh my god i was
just trying to find a dog toy we could have just made her a
new dog toy the squeaky toy could have been the death of us
all and it nearly was do not laugh that's hard not to try
okay okay all right at least i got armor though it fits nice
okay but there is only one thing there's only one concern
that i have it covers up the nipple but don't worry i can
fix that i can always free the nipple there we go
Freedom!
Okay, now where are we?
On this one side quest that we've been on.
Alright, we need...
Okay, wait, actually, we gotta upgrade too.
I'm gonna grab that.
And that.
I assume they're very good upgrades.
Press L while barehanded to quickly recall...
Oh, wait, that is pretty neat.
to consume the meter and activate enhances.
Oh!
Okay, that's pretty neat too.
Arfreya, your turn.
How does she go Valkyrie mode?
Does she just do it herself?
Like,
does it, like, activate on her own?
Because I'm, like, confused a little bit.
Oh, she does it randomly.
Okay.
I was, like, wondering, how does that even happen?
Why would I go here?
Is this way?
Freya, there's something I've always wanted to ask.
What was it?
Z-Closs, welcome to Tomato Club.
Welcome, welcome.
The tomato farm.
I'm going tired.
Oh, yes.
One of the many occasions Odin saw I really want to go to
Tomato Club.
I'm Miss Tomato.
I wish I could say that was the worst of his husbandly
habits.
What wager?
I've told this story, brother.
And now she may tell her own.
There isn't that much to tell.
I knew nothing of it at first, surely because Odin didn't
expect to lose the bet.
A mysterious mason had to build the entire wall in three
turns of the season.
Two!
It was two!
And if he was late, he'd be owed nothing.
But if he succeeded, he was promised an audience with the
Queen.
A queen?
Or so I learned one day when Odin burst into our
bedchambers, raging and half-drunk before noon, telling me
to get dressed and go see what the mason wants.
So off I went, not knowing what had truly been promised or
expected.
Dagger stashed in my robe for emergency.
And this mason, this giant in disguise...
His name was Hremthor!
He just smiled to see me, and as you said, he whispered in
my ear.
Aseer had killed his father, and he needed to know that one
day they'd burn for it.
I pointed out I was Aseer now, too, technically.
He gave me a look, as if he somehow knew better and
continued.
He said he'd built in a structural flaw behind the Asgard
Realm Tower.
I knew it!
How do we make use of it?
We don't.
It's like the Death Star!
Yeah, there's a hole!
And if Serder's approaching Asgard's wall, Oh.
Oh, it didn't matter.
They already started anyway.
All right, don't worry.
I have a giant axe.
Oh, my God.
I did not like the sound of that.
What the fuck?
It interrupted my combo!
It can do that!
Bro!
That wolf interrupted my combo!
That's cheating!
Don't just fucking interrupt the man's combo!
Oh shit.
Everyone used the...
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I swear to god I used my shield.
Please go into Valkyrie farm!
I don't understand why you're able to do that when you fight
me!
There we go.
Like when she's fucking beating shit out of me, she went
full Valkyrie.
But for these guys, she's like, well, nah, where's it?
Here we go.
I'll go this way.
What the way?
like i don't understand when she was valkyrie mode she beat
the shit of me but she won't use it here we're getting our
shit kicked in well i was getting my shit kicked in she was
just watching
yeah boss when you fight them versus the bot versus when you
unlock them as a playable character
i don't know if i got it
must be something i can collab all right where's the white
paint oh there it is the red paint i knew i was like where's
the red paint there's wet red paint somewhere only a hunch
he showed me who he really was odin asked me to cast a
protection spell on him the one i used on my son but the way
it drove our boy mad i refused he was furious throwing every
object he could find destroyed the river I'm such a kid.
It was only coldness after that.
I tried to make it work.
No one could have lived like that, Your Majesty.
Wait, who did she want to cast the spell on?
Like, who did Odin wanted the spell to be used on?
Guys, think of the Super Chat thinking, thank you.
To be fair, those guys didn't kill you.
Okay, true, true.
That's a fair point.
But they could, they could, she could channel that anger.
Oh, on himself.
Oh.
I think it would have made him like A more fucked up person
Yeah
Wanted to live forever Oh I see Yeah but she said Like you
know the challenge I hate of me killing her son To like
those guys instead Channel it healthily In a healthy way
Look Over there Look where Where Where Oh.
Oh, she's over here.
I feel like there's something in here.
But, like, how do I actually...
How do I open that?
There is something in here.
How the fuck do you open that?
There?
Oh, it is pretty.
Okay.
Arrow than axe?
The freeze!
It's gone.
Where did he go?
Oops.
Oopsie.
Does that
reach it?
No.
Okay, wait.
Not one more.
Does that reach it?
No?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wait.
Can I reach that?
No.
Oh, my God.
Not again.
All right, hero.
God, fucking...
Oh, my God.
Round two!
all right there we go there we go we did it we did see we
got better at it guys we got better
no no i figured it out i figured i got better at it i
improved there's improvement it took us three minutes
instead of 20 this time we're getting faster it's like speed
running guys
Oh my god.
There we go.
Just one more.
Where's the last pot?
This is how we got here.
Where the fuck is the last one?
Oh, is it that?
I can't tell.
Is that a pot up there?
Is it that?
Does it look like?
No, not that.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the last one?
I swear to God if it's like gamers don't look up situation.
I swear to fucking God.
Oh there it is.
I fucking knew it.
It's always gamers don't look up.
I hit that?
I do.
Okay.
Didn't I hit that, right?
God damn it.
Okay.
Maybe up here?
I hit those?
There we go.
I do hit those.
All right, nice.
Free loot!
Yay!
Another alpha.
Okay, nice.
I got more apples.
I will say the puzzles are getting a little bit more
obnoxious.
They're getting a little bit more fucked up.
Yeah!
I never thought I'd come back here.
Huh?
The Venier Shrine.
Wait, how did they get in here?
That's not fair.
I thought we were here first.
Reverse, of course.
I was gonna say, I don't fuck this.
Oh, shit!
It doesn't belong here.
We must get rid of it.
Okay, but how did he get in here?
Okay, um, this is a little awkward.
Oh, he's crawling.
He's walking very slowly towards me.
Yeah, right.
um he's still heading over lady he's heading just very
slowly walking to me don't worry what is oh he turned around
okay okay you turn around okay that's fine oh he saw me
again all right let's let me just let him walk a bit away
from the entrance so i have some space here all right here
up in the going valkyrie mode would be pretty nice right now
oh yeah oh my god fuck oh and then he shows up too okay guys
i i have my own fight to worry about right now like
please i have my own fight please fight here oh my god fight
them not me oh my god this is get out of here like get your
ass out of here are you serious I'm trying so hard to my I'm
trying there's too many people on me oh my god are you come
on let me oh my Oh my god, my hands are cold.
Oh my god, my hands are cold!
I can't do anything!
My hands are cold!
There you go.
I got it, I did it!
I ate fat!
I'm trying!
My hands are too cold!
Okay, that's good, that's fine.
Does this block it?
Don't worry, I'm blocking it.
I'm blocking it.
Okay, that's fine.
Open, open, open.
Boom!
Okay, that didn't matter.
All right, nice.
Yeah, we did it.
Fucking right, get out of here.
This place.
That used to be sacred.
Now it sits abandoned.
Vandalized.
Hopefully the objects I'm looking for are still here.
Yeah, hopefully, whatever the fuck it is.
Made me go all the way here for it.
I could be on the main storyline right now, but they told
me, they told me you'll be super strong if I do this.
Roy, welcome to Tomato Canal!
Welcome, welcome!
Oh my god, stupid fucking poison flower shit.
Okay.
is this oh my god i fucked it up all right oh my god i'm
gonna wait for this to reset i i didn't even mess it up uh
i'm gonna do it here i'll reset all of it all right i'm
resetting all the sigils okay i reset it okay there you go
one oh she's tired i'm very tired too lady It's not just
you.
Touch this?
God damn it.
Okay, not there.
There we go.
Nice.
Where's the other one?
What the fuck?
Where's the other?
I guess I have to go to the other side.
Kratos, I see something.
What do you see?
Okay, explain.
Like, all right.
Maybe if you could explain what you see instead of saying
words, woman.
Describe what you see.
Verbalize your thoughts.
Please.
Oh.
No, I don't think I will.
So much about that day, I wish I could change.
If only I've seen the signs.
Where's the mother?
Motherflower.
Or is it just there to be an asshole?
Second rut.
Get shielded.
Oh, there it is.
Give me a sec.
It's fine.
That's the risk I'm willing to take.
Are you fucking Okan?
Alright, that's fine.
Oh my god, I didn't mean to do that.
Oh, it's fine.
That's fine.
I actually meant to do that.
Alright.
Give me your loot.
Anything else?
Oh, what are you looking at?
Oh, how do I get there?
Where's the red paint?
Red paint?
Doka?
Oh, reading time.
Guys, it doesn't seem like a 10-minute side quest anymore.
This doesn't seem like it.
I thought it was a quick in and out.
But I'm starting to believe it less and less.
that's it that's it you make daddy very angry get out of
here oh my god it's poison the crest of the hughley family
just the quick quest they said
all right i'm not feeling so good
My HP is very, very low.
It's on that pedestal by the balcony.
Yeah, you did not have to scream.
You really have to scream that?
Oh, I'm fucking, I hate that cheeky bullshit.
Fuck, damn it.
You think you're so good just because you have no magic!
You fight like a pussy!
Fight like a fucking pussy!
That's right, I said it.
Alright, nice.
Easy.
Look at this.
Alright, what?
This?
What is this?
Is that your wedding crown?
What is that?
Oh.
to you a symbol of commitment after the ceremony he had a
new one made every week oh that's romantic he stopped when i
refused to teach him the old magic oh my people used to send
me gifts too so i wouldn't forget home but after the birth
of my son they stopped too i mean that was pretty romantic
of him to do so you think about it
What?
Like, new crown every week?
It's like she's getting a new designer bag every week, if
you think about it.
Alright.
I learned the leather N.
Let's head back and I can take a better look.
How do I get down here?
And that's the leather N.
Oh?
a mega fire there we go i was gonna say what happened but i
feel nothing perhaps what you see cannot be found in a
circuit you may be right
oh oh oh didn't see these guys where did they come from i
was gonna say i don't know what did they get
That's right.
Get over here!
Yeah!
Get grabbed!
Is that it?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's a wolf.
That's right.
What's he gonna do, huh?
Nothing.
That's right.
You got slowly head, tummy.
Can't do shit.
You know what?
I have so much time.
Oh, shit!
He's getting closer!
It's okay.
That's right.
What's he gonna do?
Oh, shit!
They're slowly back away.
Okay, that's illegal.
Why did he broke my combo?
He can do that?
Oh, fuck.
That's right.
That's what I do for combo breakers.
You never break a man's combo.
That's the number one rule.
You never fuck over a man's combo.
Literally face off.
How do I get the other...
Oh, here you go.
Read.
The word isn't complete.
It's missing a piece.
What do I do?
What do I do, Zen?
I don't know what to do.
Yeah?
The door is shut.
Memory serves.
We'll need to light both of those torches to open it.
Both of those torches?
Oh, these torches?
Oh, okay.
That's easy.
I got this.
Torch one.
This is a mystic fire.
Its flames are short-lived.
Oh.
Two.
Oh, shit.
Oh, did I do it?
that oh I have to do it at once maybe I have to do it both
at the same time
no wait
yeah I was gonna say I have to light it both at the same
time okay maybe I move it a bit more here
okay I fucked it up I gotta reset this alright give me a sec
I'm resetting the sigils I see something alright here we go
I reset it one two three one two three there you go oh what
can I grip though like there we Yay!
Yoink!
My loot.
Okay, but I didn't understand how short it was.
Like, how short is short lived?
Oh, hey!
Can I read in the middle?
Oh, I can't read in the middle of a fight.
I don't know what to do.
He doesn't protect his legs.
I mean, that works too, I guess.
That's stupid!
Always have to block your feet.
Yeah, all right time to read again.
It's a denouncement from my people placed during my wedding.
Oh, that's sad.
Oh, traitor.
Oh, that's so sad.
It's like, I can't believe you made out of your out of your
kind.
How could you portray your kind?
I'm playing some sick-ass music, though.
What the fuck did I hit?
That was not what I hit.
I'm pretty sure I threw my axe to the right.
Wait, he's regenning.
Wait, who's healing him?
Where's the healer?
Oh, you!
You little goblin!
Think I didn't see you?
Alright, there you go.
That's right.
No mage now.
I killed your white mage.
Bam!
There you go.
Easy.
That's right.
Right, what do you do when I bone rush your healer?
That's how I feel when I play support.
Man, anything?
Healer down.
Alright.
Oh, what's this?
That's cute as a chalice.
From the ceremony.
Oh, from the wedding ceremony.
I don't die meta.
I taught her die meta.
We drank from the lover's chalice until we could hardly
stand.
Damn.
in him that night about wanting an apology from Freyr.
That's cute.
Odin reassured me that he'd be the only family I'd need.
Oh, that's very manipulative.
Isolate her from her family and be like, I'm the only one
you need, girl.
You don't need no family and friends when I can be your best
friend forever.
That's actually so manipulative.
Oh, Odin just gives me the ick right now.
The word is complete, but I still can't read it from here.
That's what end.
Yeah, he's pretty scummy.
Is there not, like, a little shortcut?
Oh, my God.
They go all the way back here.
The pain only grows.
Yeah, he has a lot of red flags.
What more do I need to do?
I don't think I'm starting to feel like Odin might be a very
bad husband guys.
I'm not sure yet though I need more I need more data to
fully confirm that or maybe he should he could be just
misunderstood guys
I'm still not fully sure yet if he's a really bad guy or
like you know maybe he's just a bad boyfriend
All right.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Or just very misunderstood.
Exactly.
My final tie to Asgard.
What is that?
We drove that sword into the pillar together.
The sword was forged for the ceremony.
The symbol of our union.
That's a really nice sword.
Mona.
She need help?
Because she doesn't want to let go.
She hasn't moved on yet.
Mona!
What the fuck is you still into that guy for?
Bro.
What's keeping you attached to it?
him the deepest wounds form the strongest bonds oh he she
trauma bonded with him oh bastard said it is part of our
vows i hate it when he's right
the heart was what the heart was part of me i can't sever i
bond to my son to the valkyries oh That damn realm isn't
just Odin's.
She had happy memories there, too.
That belongs to me too.
She's stuck with Odin, like how League players are stuck
with that shit, Mova.
You can never leave.
The pain he caused is his.
for for league this sword no longer holds our legacy it
holds her future but it will serve as mine a much more
fitting use for it
wait so what changed that let her new sword unlock
customized freya's loadout oh new sword so what changed to
let her be able to pull the sword out Okay, not gonna lie,
her old sword looks a lot better.
Like, I guess, like, this has...
This has freeze now, but I think her old sword looks, like,
nicer.
Acceptance?
So she accept...
Oh.
She got over her son.
Oh, I see.
So she just accepted, she accepted, like, what...
What happened, and she's, like, just moving on type deal.
Okay.
she changed what the sword meant to her oh okay all right
what do we want to use okay the steel heart this is what we
had before control a deadly poison gas that seeks disrupt in
oh yeah no that sense stun end by frost yeah fuck that that
shit sound that shit sounds strong all right armor
no that that blue is just too much
She has ties to Asgard, but is a tie to her son in Valkyrie?
That makes sense.
Yeah, that's what I thought, too.
I was like, she moved on.
She had happy memories of Asgard.
Not just, like, with Odin.
There's, like, happy moments in her life.
That wasn't just being controlled by Odin.
Alright.
Yeah, that color is not working.
That's not your color.
You shouldn't...
I don't think blue works for you.
Oh, my God.
We're finally gonna Request the story.
We've done it.
We did it, guys.
Yeah, I know there was like one word.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, shit.
What the?
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Bro, what the fuck?
Where did that wolf come from?
It was like a fucking car crash.
I actually did not expect that.
Oh my god, I don't know what the fuck to do.
God's literally behind me.
Oh, hey, Derek.
There you go.
Alright, nice!
Let him, Perry!
Oh my god, I fucking cursed.
There you go.
And then!
That's right!
that's right what you gotta do now if i may since when have
you ever asked for permission it's just i owe you my life
such as it is and i i caused you so much pain put you in a
terrible situation oh that freya i'm truly sorry i wanted to
end that see i told you guys see it's like riding a bike i
was just on 500 ping It took a while for the information to
travel.
I'm forever in your debt.
I appreciate that.
Even if you can't help being an obnoxious know-it-all.
Oh, look, see, we're all apologizing.
We're all apologizing and seeing sorry.
Look at that.
We're a happy family now!
Look at that character development.
Why would I go?
Okay.
Where is the exit?
All right, there it is.
All right, down I go.
Now, where is my boat?
All right, oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
Oh, my heart.
My hat, you...
Oh, my God.
There's two of them now!
Oh, my...
Okay.
Holy fuck, my heart.
Oh, my...
Oh my god, okay, I actual, oh my god.
No, you guys don't understand, Asher freaked me out.
I was not ready for that.
Holy fuck.
That fucked me up, guys.
I just fucked me up.
Oh, I'm not okay.
am not oh my god and I'm paralyzed I am not okay guys this
is not it it truly was not it
Jesus Christ oh it's fine it's fine oh oh my I was not I'm
not ready for that.
I was like, yay!
Oh!
That was not it.
Actual, actual fucking jump scare.
Are you fucking getting it?
Really?
Oh my god, I did watch it though.
I saw it.
I just...
Look, he said watch it.
He didn't explain what else to do.
I was just...
All I do was watch!
Oh my god, I should have been it.
There you go.
There is like no cooldown for that, which I noticed.
But where's the other guy?
Oh, there he is.
is.
There you go.
Oh, you saw that!
That's
like...
Oh shit.
Range time!
Boom!
Smash!
I'm so angry!
That's like, oh shit!
Range time!
Boom!
Smash!
I'm so angry!
That's like, get your ass out of here, fucking jump scare
motherfucker.
That's right.
You think you can jump scare me?
That's fucking right now.
Look at who's dead.
I killed your fucking wife too.
How do you see your wife in hell?
Too much for that boat.
All right, nice.
We did it.
Oh my god.
My boat!
How would I get home?
Oh, I got another boat.
Okay, never mind.
I have two boats.
I know.
An arrogant man once told me you can't change the past.
Thank god I have two boats.
I think he might be right.
It's been a while since I've had a confidence.
Would the god of few words lend me his ear now and again?
As long as I am needed.
Alright, off we go.
We did it.
We can go home now.
couldn't see her son almost forgot what he looked like
oh my god and we're flirting too she liked what she saw i
never asked how it felt to lose your head she let see me
beat up two alligators if you wish to derive some
satisfaction from my pain i'm afraid you'll be disappointed
kratos swung swift and true didn't your brother i felt an
area all right guys i'm gonna grab food real quick guys i'm
gonna reheat some food up real fast i didn't need lunch yet
i'll bring back guys i think i deserve a lunch break after
beating up those two
crocodiles by myself some water oh you refill my wire i
can't check i'm so i should have a cough drop in my mouth
i'm gonna finish my cough drop before i eat my food uh cyber
astrum thank you to having a conversation.
Shady, Juge, W, Papa, Smurf, Nexi, thank you for the super
chat.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
Jayla, Carl, and Astrum, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What are we talking about in particular?
Giving up your body.
Do I regret exchanging my life for my freedom?
That's a question I ask myself every day.
Oh, is it broken?
Why is it broken?
I'm chat.
Glad to be out in the world.
Oh, yeah, it is.
Why is it broken?
Let me try.
Is it still broken?
Let me see.
Nope, it's not.
That's so weird.
I don't know why it's broken, lady.
Um.
Alright, it's the right one.
But it's fixed now.
It's fixed now.
That's weird.
Okay, okay.
Strange.
It is.
I have no idea why it's like that.
Oh, I tried to figure this out.
Let's see.
Oh, it's good.
It's shiny.
This crest.
Ooh.
It's mine.
It's yours?
What is it?
That Lunda's armor?
Engine over.
I can fix it up right quick.
Would have been ashamed to have left that behind.
Let's do it.
What other new armor can I make now?
Can I make this?
Oh, I am!
Wait, is Lunas armor the strongest?
Or what?
Very good.
I have enough.
Asgardian Inget?
Oh, I already have that.
Alright.
Is that the strongest armor in the game?
Sure, I'm open.
Let's see.
Now for the goddess.
Nope, just me.
No?
I am.
It was not the strongest.
That music can be even stronger.
I will keep all of that.
Special items?
Is there anything I want to miss?
Nah.
Everything's fine.
Oh yeah, I'm only halfway in this.
It's only halfway.
We're gonna It only took two hours, but we're finally done
with the side quest.
Oh my fucking god.
What?
What is this?
The Elven Sanctum?
The Eyes of Odin?
Oh, fuck that.
I'm fucking progressing the game.
It only took two hours.
Before you see the lad again, might we discuss an approach?
where he has been that is my approach ah classic spartan
diplomacy wait what did you say odin invited him to asgard
and then he disappeared for two days wait that's pretty
that's pretty suspicious don't underestimate odin's powers
of persuasion come on i'm only halfway why wouldn't he do
the same with yours he doesn't discriminate yeah but i just
want to spend time with my new wife If we lose Artaeus, it's
fine.
You can always make a new one.
Well, look either.
Glad you could make the trip, your goddessness.
I put your sigil magic on the young turd's bow.
But then he and Sindri got into it over something.
I don't rightly know who's yelling at who in there.
But I figure they both got it coming.
Here we go.
Hello.
What is his purpose anyway?
This whole spectral squirrel business.
You can shoot out your feelings into little ghosties.
I suppose that is a slightly in elegant way of putting it.
These spectral versions of myself are aspects of my
personality that I often find distracting at best.
My ability not only lets me cast them away and provide some
temporary peace of mind, it also allows me to see what goes
on.
outside the tree why not school with yourself as the eternal
caretaker of the tree i may not leave its confines all part
of the deal but worth it for the immortality and such my
spectral form still allow me to see the outside world albeit
through slightly colorful viewpoints that's one word for it
that better form of yours is a nasty piece of work i'm
standing right here you know i'd apologize for him but where
would it end Please come back anytime.
Oh, he's just, he's just like a little lore drop thing.
Just be like, you want to know more lore about God of War.
Talks to squirrels now, huh?
He talks back!
How is that weird?
He's a talking squirrel.
Of course I'll fucking talk to him.
Spartan, thank you for this.
Spartan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Jokey, thanks for playing God of War today.
I love watching the chaos of this game after having a long
day.
Your shenanigans make me laugh.
Thank you.
They give a super chat.
You see I got waiting for you, right?
Um, I'm please You're not the center of my world.
Okay.
I have a chat Here's where I wonder why I was eating.
I had one more box of lunchables And so I was like fuck
yeah, I might as well finish it I'm literally a child right
now.
I got my little lunchables It's lunchtime coming Well, come
on then Hey, Tyr!
Wake up!
You got company!
It's lunchtime.
I gotta eat my lunchable.
You're sure he won't mind?
Mind?
He'll be thrilled.
Joints getting classier by the dick.
It's not a lunchly!
It's a lunchable!
I never thought I'd have the pleasure of seeing you again,
Frick.
Don't call me that.
that person in a long time but i'm happy to see you too i'd
feared the worst for so long what you must have been through
you guys did rebellion together so bad is what you've
suffered preya i am so so sorry to hear what happened to
balder he was only a boy when i saw him last but i know he
meant more to you than anything he's literally her son and
to forbear your vengeance in this way it's it's truly an
inspiration for those of us who believe in peace the only
peace these realms will ever know such a pussy now fucking
gotta worry what happened to him so you're not here to
prevent ragnarok you're here to bring it about i'm here to
make sure odin doesn't hurt anyone the way he hurt us i can
see how upset you forgive me i am far removed from
she's no less majestic than the last day I saw her whoa what
a thing I must be to look at whoa get away from her she's
mine only I can call her that he's so useless though like
what's the point of having him around what
you better screw his head back on and I mean tightly oh no
he's mad so you're back are you ready to answer me about
what where did you go who did you see was it odin what is
that what you think do you deny it answer me answer me boy
no of course not but so what if i did it's my future it's my
life you are my son then why don't you trust me if you want
me to trust you then tell me the truth The truth is you're
being a complete asshole.
That is true.
You can't just say, why don't you trust me when he won't
even, like, tell me anything.
It's fine if he keeps secrets.
It's fine if mom did.
That is not fine.
No secrets are hard to be set with this path.
Oh, okay.
Do I sound like I'm fine?
This is not about your mother.
What you have done is lie.
Wonder where I learned that.
That's quite enough.
Damn.
Since when do you always take his side?
Since he became the one making sense.
Look.
I was only thinking about going to Odin, but I swear it's
for a good reason.
There is no good reason to go to...
How dare you even think about it, boy?
How dare you?
I gotta stop something bad from happening.
Something bad did happen.
Look at me!
I don't have a body!
Well, it's got everyone catar-walling all of a sudden.
Atreus wants to go to Asgard.
Asgard?
Get kicked in the head or something?
Great.
I guess everybody's against me now.
You must choose who you're going to be.
Are you going to continue to lie and keep things from me?
Are you my son?
Choose?
I never get to choose.
Just leave me alone.
Oh.
Let go of me.
Let's go.
Oh, Shindo!
Oh, fuck.
I trashed.
It's Sindri.
Just let the furry overtake himself.
Oh!
Oh no.
The moment you leave this house, you're not allowed back
here.
That's very... his ward rage.
Oh shit, I have to play as a Tears now?
Oh shit, now I have to remember I'll play as him!
I just remember!
Figuring it out!
Okay, nice.
Alright, though.
Okay, that was sick, though.
I'm getting better at the parries.
You're just helping me stay warm.
Home, shoot home.
I like playing Arteus, but right now it's not it because I
just figured out how to play with my brawl play with Kratos.
So I'm like, fuck not the robot play as him!
these things when did it get so bad out here i don't know
i've been here in a while to be fair what the fuck where oh
god there's so many wait how okay i got set up a deer
there's a deer in me boom all right nice all right that's
actually a good thing to use with all the bunch up now Oh my
god, nice.
Land?
He's got a channel.
Channel his inner furry.
Oh, those are some crows.
He doesn't want to kill me.
Let the furry out.
Solid.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Someplace warm.
Damn.
Holy shit.
I'm so angry.
I'm angry.
I can figure out where to go next.
Uh, that doesn't look good.
What the fuck is that?
Is that a ghost?
Oh, nice.
What is this thing?
Some kind of white?
Nice.
I mean, I can still hit it.
Not a very good ghost.
Oh, fuck.
I will say it's not a very good ghost.
good ghost one i could just fucking hit it what is it you
want i'd fucking run
all right nice oh get parried that's right get your ass
parried bitch oh shit stun the worst ors with oh i have to
stun it now yeah oh my god
Okay, nice.
Is that it?
More ravens.
It's a pretty bad ghost.
You trying to tell me something?
If I can just shoot it.
This way.
Back to Ameritians, before you run away, why didn't you
bring a compass with you?
Blind.
Ah!
I'm trying to save your life, you big jerk.
There you go.
Gotta get out of the cold.
Yeah, I forgot to bring a jacket with me before I ran away.
Is this way?
Oh, or is it this way?
Well, I guess I'll never know which way is the right way.
All right.
I can kill him.
Boop.
Yeah.
as long as it doesn't get close to me it should be fine yeah
see easy banana thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you thank you oh oh wait these are like little oh what come
on that should have hit oh shit oh shit you're too close too
close personal space uh forget if anyone mentioned this
before but all the yellow paint markers in both games are
implied to be set by fate on every step of their path her
yellow paint persists even now oh that's cool so it's like
she knew that her husband and her son are gonna be
incompetent it's not like a true mom she knew she was like
when I died there's no way they're gonna know what the fuck
there's no way they'll know what to do and that she was
right she She was a real mom.
She's like, before I die, I gotta make sure.
A real mom moment.
Oh my god, he knows how to dodge.
Yeah.
I find shelter and then what?
Where could I go?
She knew, she was like, there's no way they could get
anything done without my help.
Following the prophecy where father ends up dead if I stay
locked up at home There's nothing I can do to stop it That's
right as guard I you're the main character Arteus you spy
Find out his plan Get control of this No,
that's the opposite of what Kratos wanted.
He was like I gotta stop him from talking to Odin And now
he's like you know what?
I am gonna talk to Odin just because you didn't want me to.
I can't go to Asgard.
It's like the...
What is it called?
You know when they tell you not to do something, you end up
doing it?
I hate you, Dad!
Yeah.
Wait, are those red leaves?
Freya's house.
He did have a sput.
oh no Charlie Charlie the turtle no Charlie he's just
sleeping right are you just sleeping please Charlie it's
just very eepy oh he's alive he's alive oh thank god okay
see I told you guys he was just very tired it's just very
eepy warm you're gonna have to stand to let me into that
house i think you can do that
come on charlie you have to do this i i can't help if you
don't oh no emily emily oh no he's forcing himself to oh he
forced himself to get up for him oh that's no buddy it's
cold here that's so fucked up close that window for snooping
around he's a good boy I don't think that's gonna fucking
help too busy hunting is down let's get you warmed up she
got too consumed from all the yeah from all the revenge
that's so fucked up Wow it's beautiful ever seen anything
like this around here before oh she neglected him from her
home in Vanahe she must have really missed it
Valkyrie armor does this go with the wings on the wall from
her friend wonder what happened to her I was like don't
worry boy I'm gonna warm you up I'm like ooh shiny thing
under how father was able to earn her forgiveness
okay buddy okay I'll get you warmed up I can't believe she
never came back to check on her house to check on you I know
right it's so fucked you deserve better um now he's like
he's not her father's like bro you almost died she didn't
even come back to warm you up
I will never forgive her even if even if she's my new mom
I'll never forgive you you're not my mom you're welcome
where do I go now I can't stay I just can't let my dad die
too there's gotta be something I can do
Odin Odin it's okay buddy i think he's here for me i'll be
okay i think okay
i'm ready take me to him it's like those time traveling
prophecy things where you're like we gotta stop this
prophecy from happening but everything his dad did ended up
pushing him towards the prophecy
Oh no, it's time.
It's time to visit the mob boss
So it's like them not knowing the prophecy would have helped
more better would have been even would have been a better
outcome Oh,
it's warm now Yeah, trying to avoid it caused it to happen
Oh then
if should have learned to swim before midgard froze over
hello hello oh my god wait is this asgard hey wait planes of
eda oh apparently not it's planes of eda
wherever this is it's beautiful it is not a sign of fumble
winter we should just live here It's very pretty.
This is Asgard.
Oh, there's the wall.
And there's a hole in that wall too.
Oh, fuck.
I guess there's also woos.
There's also woos.
And now we're friendly.
Yeah, no, I don't think so either.
Don't worry.
Right here.
Oh, shit.
Got him stupid poison.
He's fucking right.
Get out of here!
What the fuck?
Okay, that should have been a parry.
Come on.
There you go.
Get out of here.
Get out of that wall!
That's right.
Get down!
I will always have to hog around over you.
I'm the big character!
My name's in the prophecy, you know?
That's right.
Oh my god.
God fucking, I knew it.
That's it.
Oh wait, no, I shouldn't turn wolves is a waste of a good
wolf oh my god he fucking got knocked me off the high ground
there you go oh my god that's it that's it that's it there
you go invincibility frame whoop all right nice easy Is
there any loot here?
Damn right, I parried a projectile.
What, like it's hard or some shit?
Oh my god.
Okay.
But...
Yeah, on my chest.
It's beautiful here.
Not a sign of Femblewinter.
Okay, as you already said that.
Oh.
You could have led me around those.
Even if he led me away from them, it won't stop me.
I'm hungry for blood!
That's right!
He's going through puberty right now!
Alright, let's get him out though.
Alright, I got let out all these hormones.
Nice.
Yay, money.
Uh, oh, here, look.
Oh, wait, what the fuck is that?
Yeah, danger.
I know.
Oh, my God.
For God, I can swap arrows.
I don't even remember what.
I was like, oh, my God, wait.
Oh, my God.
I have different arrows, guys.
I actually legitimately don't remember what my...
I don't remember.
I don't remember what the other arrow does.
You guys remember?
Because I don't.
What is this?
What is this arrow?
What does that arrow even do again?
It hits people.
Thank you guys.
It's purple.
Well, this might be the craziest thing I've ever done.
into a wolf what do you mean how is this the craziest thing
you literally turn into a bear and a wolf hold on I'm coming
she's got to find a way through enhances the elemental
damage what does that even mean everything I came to Asgard
for us on the other side of that wall what am I gonna say to
Odin hi I I came to be your apprentice, I guess.
But it doesn't mean I like serve you now.
Not in a foretold by prophecy kind of way.
I'm gonna send that out.
Mm, fuck it, let's also send out the deer.
Might as well, bam, deer time.
What the fuck, he exploded.
okay all right I mean it's just two worlds oh shit that shit
explodes oh my guys all right nice oh my god god fucking
damn it oh now there's two of them what do you mean there's
two of them
Okay, well, I'll get rid of that.
It's like, oh, no.
It's already gone.
Then fight back.
How do I get past the wall?
I never came up with a mere story about Ruther.
Oh, he didn't listen.
Oh, he wasn't there.
He only told Frey about it.
And I didn't think to ask.
God damn it.
He doesn't know.
He's a way at the house.
Did she move in with us?
Is she my new mom?
Focus, Loki.
Okay.
So many questions.
Oh yeah, he didn't.
He was like, what the fuck?
Wait a minute.
Why is she here?
It's like, wait a minute.
Do I have a new mom now?
I don't know.
I don't remember how to do this.
Like, how do I burn this?
Is this a Kratos thing?
What am I supposed to do?
I can't light that It's a way to light it Yeah, I was gonna
say Is dad supposed to show up later?
Yeah, okay, dad will be here soon Yeah, I was gonna say I'm
pretty sure I don't have Father would just burn this away
with his blades But what can I do?
Help God Huh Maybe that sigil magic on my bow can I What did
Brock say?
Not?
If I could just get that fire to spread to the bramble.
There you go.
There we go.
There you are.
Easy.
Okay, L2.
Yeah, all right.
I figured it out.
Wait, does it work from downstairs?
I wonder?
Okay, wait.
Maybe it works downstairs.
Oh, yeah, it does.
Gonna need a better angle on that fire.
Oh, it doesn't work like that.
Alright.
There we go.
Ah, see?
I don't need my dad.
I'm a strong, independent boy.
Okay.
look at that don't need my dad to do this I'm my own man
yeah he's done what is this why is the seeking that
ricochets between enemies oh that's strong yeah I'll do that
that shit looks fun too okay have any skill upgrades oh i do
all right hold evading but i'm just gonna increase my
archery just because i spam that a lot all right here we go
we're off to see the wizard the wonderful wizard of ask
guard Wait, I'm not allowed to shoot the crow.
He's on the list as well.
They're all on the list.
It's like those wildlife reserves.
Oh, there's dwarves.
Or people?
I can't tell if they're smaller now.
Because they're so far away.
Getting my bangs.
Well, there's nothing to see this way except the big one.
wall is there a gate to go through nope not unless you're an
ace of your god but i guess you know that if you were an ace
of your god me no i'm from midgard what no me too i'm
skilled here oh is that gonna be my bro are you gonna be
homies for life from midgard yep the uh all father saved us
from the desolation gave us a safe place to settle but we
don't go in there can't get into the city unless you know
magic do you you don't know magic do you a little bit yeah
what no shit you walk through walls not yet huh finally just
climb over it A friend my own age.
No, aren't you afraid of dying?
Well, yeah.
I mean, look at that.
But, oh, no, wait.
Wait.
You know the all-father?
I'm sort of his apprentice.
No shit!
No fucking way!
I'm not sure.
How many of the students?
I don't know.
you'll tell me you think he'll take me as apprentice too you
don't know okay i'm gonna go climb that wall now oh my god
bro his friends are never gonna believe him well this i
gotta see he's like guys guys i met another human oh i he
knows magic he's like sure you did my life but i don't owe
him my pro is just straight up lying asgard is a gated
community is that hogan is that hogan your guide who odin's
raven you know from hogan and moonin it's a pretty good guy
though yeah i just don't call him you know it's because like
i don't call him hogan i call him like ginn so like you know
we're tight like that so that's why i forgot his actual name
i'm gonna do it one step at a time i guess know you little
bro with hands watch this you're gonna be so impressed bam
that's not really with hats it's a rope seem like a good guy
i really hope i am not about to watch you die i didn't watch
this too it's like it's like jackass right now he's filming
like i gotta go in like film this for me i want to be on
jackass progress i've made wow yeah that's That's great.
Can I use that?
I mean, a little ironic as last words, but...
What was that?
Nothing.
Do a flip!
Oh my god, is my bro filming me right now?
I gotta send this audition tape to Jackass.
Oh, it's like the...
Yeah, it's the Netflix stream of the guy that was climbing
the fucking tower.
He's gonna send that over to Netflix.
I'm gonna get $500,000.
$500,000.
Okay, not gonna lie.
Jesus Christ.
The fact that he has airtime when he's jumping is actually
insane.
I'm getting my Netflix money.
See that?
That's why I'm Odin's apprentice and you ain't.
Can you still see me from here?
I don't think you see me from here anymore.
He's like, where did he go?
Is he alive?
Okay.
Yeah, bro defies physics right now just keep climbing and
now where right here boom oh what someone else climbed here
wait I wasn't even the first guy here totally fine look did
you see me is my bro still filming bro you're still filming
right hey Hogan bro my mom apparently knew I was gonna climb
this wall Would you?
Yeah, that's what I thought you'd say.
Thank God my mom put down all the fucking yellow paint for
me.
Oh yeah, I gotta see that?
Oh my, not that one though.
Does it say up here?
Okay, I'm getting very angry.
What?
That hits me?
Oh my god.
all right fuck this that's it that's fucking right that's
rob will corner camp you
this guy is so fucking tanky not gonna lie oh my god thank
god now i can fucking whack oh goodbye
live the king oh yeah i heard silver and the new deadlock
character the wolf girl is pretty ass apparently she has
like a 20 or 30% like win rate
hello let me climb this hello okay sorry i just didn't touch
the floor yet i can only climb chains when i I wonder why I
can't hear your thoughts.
It sure seemed like Odin could.
That was you and our cabin, right?
You and your brother, I guess?
Taking that- Yeah, floating ghost died from fall damage.
His- a ghost's one weakness, fall damage.
He's like, no!
I don't know where the floor is.
I guess I died now.
I bet I'm past the worst of it now.
or not nope i'll go to the other side
how the did this guy this guy made it to the hole and just
dies like he was like almost there just let me pass through
or this have it your way
oh goodbye don't you hate it when you just die from fall
damage
So sweet.
Oh my god, there's more?
I swear to God, I just want this.
Is there some... Okay, there's a fucking thing over there.
Yeah, there is.
Like, where are they all coming from?
Oh, there it is.
There we go.
Oh, there's more.
Oh?
Is there another one over there?
Yeah, there is.
There has to be.
Oh.
Oh, I'm running out.
Alright, I gotta get up there.
There we go.
Alright, now back downstairs.
Gotta grab my loot.
That's when we know we're all equal.
No matter what, whether you're a ghost, a demon, or a devil,
or a skeleton, or a monster, we all die from fall damage.
No one ever escapes from fall damage.
All right, nice.
Gravity rules.
No one can escape from gravity.
Whoa.
Okay.
I mean, can I go from here?
Looks a little like Soundstone.
How come I can't do anything to it, though?
Oh, there's stuff here.
Nice.
Oh!
Huh?
Can't do anything.
buying both claps to free the counterweight I did I thought
there's the claps here and then the claps over there oh R2
whoops my bad yeah that's my bad thing gotta do both sides
though all right no I just didn't realize it's R2 I can't I
can't do it with R1 there you go this might work That makes
sense.
Here we go.
Whoa!
Shit!
Apparently I was not on the same page of what the plan was.
I was like, yeah, I definitely know the plan.
What the fuck?
Alright, nice.
Oh shit.
there you go where are the rest where are they all coming
from what the fuck where's your mom oh okay they were they
were orphans get to fly I'm doing what I can all right nice
why don't why doesn't Odin just send all this crows over and
then have all the crows just pick me up just got to climb a
little further maybe a lot further i'm pretty sure if all
the crows like pick me up like i can make it this way hey
hugen how about i tell you a story once there was a giant
named loki who thought it'd be a good idea to accept odin's
invitation to asgard
so odin tested loki expecting him to climb by himself all
the way
I'm okay oh my god this actually is like the Netflix special
no equipment it was a thousand meters it's all right just
keep climbing just keep climbing how hard to breathe Loki
kept climbing one okay maybe I should stop telling the story
while I'm trying to Loki.
Loki may be time and place.
Time and place.
Gotta get that 500k.
Nowhere to go, but up.
Keep going.
Come on.
Can't stop now.
We're almost there.
I know I said that like 10 minutes ago, but this time...
Oh my gosh.
We're definitely almost there now.
Jesus Christ, that is a big ass jump.
I can do this.
How did my mom paint all this?
Bro.
My mom is like, now go over here, son.
Oh?
Hello.
Hello?
Oh, that does not feel safe.
So, what?
Part of the enormous wall made you think.
Oh.
Visitors must be welcome.
I was sent for, actually.
By Odin?
No, it's a bouncer.
You a regular guy.
Likely story.
Then why are you out there?
And not in here?
why don't we ask them together where does the crows go wait
my crows can back me up my talking crows hello where is he
wait where are the crows oh now they decide to not show up
oh okay after they were like fucking hounding me while i was
trying to climb the wall where the fuck are the Crows,
aren't they supposed to vouch for me?
Where are the fucking crows?
What do you want with the likes of you?
You get unmuted.
You don't even know.
They're just watching this all.
That's fuck.
Think you could pull me up or...
No, I don't think I will.
I think maybe I'll do it.
drop you no wait that's not cool goodbye wait wait wait wait
wait come mad the all-father's gonna be when when he finds
out you killed his guest loki of the yotner but you're loki
the yotner the enemy of my people I am not your enemy I'm
even the worst thing to say
I will be the judge of that
Huh?
What is he gonna do?
Also, now the fucking crows Okay, now the crows Don't show
up Is this Heimdall?
This is Heimdall?
Now feel free to drink in the splendor of Asgard He is the
bouncer It's the actual Bouncer of Asgard I knew it steal
anything that is not nailed down that is sure to impress
your hosts
yeah oh i'm gonna hate him oh i mean just no one really no
one really likes bouncers to be fair it is my job next
question what is your job i protect the realm i love from
trouble and you think i'm trouble you just met me and i can
already see you are eager to prove yourself way too eager
probably due to an overshadowing father figure you can never
live up to oh damn yes i would also guess that you are and
see through my soul entitled and impulsive you don't know me
i was like you don't look like yourself oh you are here to
help people hmm no no you are here to help yourself to
manipulate and lie to whoever you have to to get what you
want not true I know you're young your voice probably
dropped while you were climbing the wall but what a twisted
little soul you have you are chaos in a spiffy Is he
psycho-analyzing me?
Nothing good is going to come from you being in Asgard.
The first year psychology student right there.
It takes Psych 101 once and now thinks he can psychoanalyze
everyone.
I guess that makes us allies.
Ghoul Topper.
Who loves me the most?
loves me the most wow whoa that's almost as impressive as
boulder taming a dragon boulder had the luxury of not caring
how badly he got burnt i i would think them dominate them
fair and square oh wait i gotta be on on the back
that's a big ass cat oh are these all asia gods what you
think all asia are gods?
But Skilder told me that only... Oh, well, Skilder told you.
Clearly whoever that is must be the authority on Asir gods,
not the Asir god you are currently talking to.
You literally know nothing of our culture, do you?
I know lots of things.
I know a giant built that wall.
A giant.
Built the wall that keeps out the giants.
Krimther, son of Thamur.
I know the whole story.
decaled me with the revisionist tales of Asgard's
architectural history.
That's what they say, only winners write history.
Is that only palace?
Palace.
Do you think the Allfather needs to puff himself up like
some mortal chieftain?
I guess not.
That is the great lodge, which the Allfather built with his
own hands.
Call me a revisionist.
I'm sorry if that is a letdown for you.
you see does not need to flaunt it emerges when the time is
right don't you agree oh whoa he's such an asshole i love
him wait wait what i thought we were going to oh yeah you
see the thing is you too so hi you don't know that I thought
we cool.
What happened?
That's right.
What if you know?
It could be wrong, you know?
Oh, shit.
Damn!
Shit!
I mean, I literally...
That was... I literally bit his head.
up next well it can't be you right funny thing oh my god
wait wait he just he's just slowly walking very sure oh oh
oh he's just deflecting by arrows oh my god it's okay i'll
pay you were counting on that to protect you oh he's just
walking menacely towards me guys You're gonna stop me from
seeing Odin.
He always try to grab me.
What?
That doesn't even make sense.
What I do is try to very slowly grab me.
Glad to see you are awake.
What?
Oh.
What he deserves.
Is that it?
Is this all you have to show me?
He's acting!
Oh, that one fell.
He has...
Speedax!
Sure!
Completely ineffective!
Oh shit!
Wait, he actually grabbed me!
I'm kidding, Orobar.
He said cheating.
Unimpressed.
You should probably stay down.
Oh!
Odin's coming.
I love the eye effects.
That's like Heimdell's power, right?
foretell foresee everything that i feel like he's literally
a like a psychic yeah i thought i smelled something he can
foresee everything take one more step you're not gonna like
how this ends really and how do you intend to stop me look
into my eye you tell me
i's trying to posture him really it's like you made it i am
so honored i i see you've met heimdall he reads minds for me
the boy is false all father this young man who is my guest
is covered in mud care to explain he means to betray you huh
is that true Loki you a little trickster he can oh of course
he means to betray me huh Heimdall why else would he come
I've given him no reason to trust me not yet but he's got
some very big questions and I have So many answers to get.
What are you up to?
Loki, a trickster?
No way.
Oh, wait.
The app, like, he still has the scar.
And you clean yourself up.
Wasn't there a theory about how Loki was able to trick
Heimdell?
Heimdell, will you just relax?
I remember when the game first came out.
You were kidding me first thing?
See?
What?
That's not good enough for you?
get out of here
he's a lot i know very perceptive but sometimes he just
forgets to think you know hey i got some places to be oh
yeah why couldn't he just do that instead of me climbing the
fucking wall savage welcome to tomato farm welcome i know he
sounds like he's on it from new yorker Boston.
He literally sounds like a mob boss.
That was a test.
Between my ex-wife and my disgruntled former employee, he's
not exactly getting an unbiased view.
But you, you're curious.
Open-minded.
That's important.
I'm walking here.
Oh, they're prepping for a war.
The Ragnarok.
after you went to front here but i suppose spending time
with him is punishment enough isn't it at least my mirror
never lost his sense of humor but yeah that's all behind us
now i like to keep looking forward hey hey hey i want them
trained not decapitated just keep it below the neck all
right is that really what you do when i'm not here oh father
queen gana the ain't her yard are ready for your blessings
that's why i'm here isn't it Hmm.
I guess there's a new Valkyrie queen.
Great soldiers, these ain't here we are.
But they tend to come out of Valhalla a little foggy.
I do what I can for them, help them.
Remember who they were in life.
That's important, don't you think?
A sense of identity.
Gives things meaning.
Moon, Thin, Nafen, Rothgar.
Oh.
Moon, Thin, Thin, Thorn.
Moon, Thin, Thorn.
Give him special powers.
Oh, shit.
He's roiding them up.
Brainwashing.
Oh, he brainwashed those guys.
Wait, what?
What do you mean by brainwashing?
The magic steroids.
Yeah.
Ah, the box.
Good.
Those are for him.
understand you're an avid reader these are you changed
outfits for my personal collection uh thanks you're again
those better not be mushrooms i smell listen i appreciate
your offer but i'm really not sure what you're expecting
from me right now you're just visiting loki one step at a
time steady there carl but with all respect you need to know
i came to study not to serve another servant is the last
thing i need wait if they're spirits why are they drinking
with curiosity someone will take initiative that looks good
is that brazed why do they need to eat if they're just is it
because i'm half if they're just spirits so store they're
just ghosts try to stay awake for me okay but look don't
overthink it i have a project i think you'll be interested
in a major learning opportunity or a book of us what about
my family to get hurt why would i hurt anybody the truce is
all i've been asking for from the start if you recall look
you're here now stop worrying it's all gonna be fine almost
to your room my room my room just over here wait this is
this is the best place i've ever lived in oh is this like
thereby hala and more importantly i am not your father all
father there's a situation that needs your attention Oh,
father.
I'm not your father.
Oh, it's Sif!
Say hello to Loki.
This is him.
Here.
In our home.
How nice.
That's right.
Everything all right in New Midgard.
The refugees are fine.
The situation is with the dwarves.
Okay, but they were pretty bad.
There she's just let you You let the boy who killed my son
into our home?
Okay, that's cool.
I guess.
That's okay.
She was so icy towards me.
I started worried she knew what I did.
Yeah, I wonder if she knows.
All right.
I'm here.
Oh, there's the dwarves.
Oh, just over there.
Oh, father.
Oh, we're back here.
We're back in dwarf land.
Oh, it's a tax guy!
It's been too long.
What's the issue now?
Give him the ultimate punishment.
Becoming a bureaucrat.
I approve these designs personally and not all that
recently, I might add.
Did you just wake up with the urge to be a pain in my ass?
Yeah.
Who's the good?
You're training pokeball kids.
You know what?
Oh, he's acting.
Good acting.
Like we never met before.
ever also with the power for those who have the power to see
the future are they like psychic or oracle what's the word
for that i have confidence in you is that either a psychic
or an oracle as promised on time on budget and of course
safely the dwarves have never let me go right seer about to
start now both oh okay good
yeah because i was like you know and that's a raven we I'm
going to let you catch your breath.
When you're ready to get to work and start getting those
answers, meet me in my study.
Oh, you see, he's in tent.
Okay.
Wait, what did Odin just said?
Oh, and help yourself do a change of clothes.
Alright, let's change clothes.
What did Odin just say?
I'm recrafted by the smiths.
I guess I could try this on.
I'll try it on.
Oh, and a new bow.
Oh, my God.
My new dad is so nice to me.
Wait, what's so bad about Odin?
Anyway.
This seems so bad.
Really increased stun from me.
Oh, I like the stun, though.
I think stun is better than cooldown.
Really increased stun from...
He's so nice, guys.
Look, he got me free stuff.
My new dad is so nice to me.
When was the last time my father gave me free stuff?
True.
Is that new PlayStation 5?
Wait, a PlayStation 6?
It was not even in the market yet.
Which is better, chat?
Acer bow or Talon bow?
Which one's better?
I will craft it, but I want to know.
Yes?
This one?
Upgrade it, then.
I'll try it out.
With the...
With the cooldown.
I like the sun, just because, like...
I feel like the sun would work better for me, but I'll try
it out.
see how i feel upgrade increases the damage dealt from this
effect
i'll craft it just to see how i feel how many can i be
equipped anyway
increases status
oh no oh
fuck it
All right, what is my uniform?
My new armor.
Where is it?
A-tier uniform.
Whoa!
Wait!
Look at the fucking quality of that!
Oh my god, the only way I can get stabbed is through my
armpit or my arm.
Wait.
Wait, I think I have a new dad.
Wait a minute, guys.
I think I have a new dad.
It was just that easy.
Just buy me a 50-90.
And dad 2.0.
Yeah, Kratos never gave me a shiny armor.
Look at this.
Oh my god.
Look at the shot on that.
That is good craftsmanship right here.
Yeah, he would just give me a life lesson.
Whoa.
Loki, right?
the irony of this isn't lost on me oh it's that sister oh i
knew it moody ah your brother really i had no idea uh-huh
all right come on your brother was an ass though enjoy what
for a thirst doctor is that it relax you got some pretty
small shoes to fill.
she didn't like his brother, right?
Like, got him.
We're better off without him, okay?
Aw, it was a deadbeat.
Trust me.
It looked like she did more work than him, to be fair.
It looked like she was like the more confident sibling.
It's a walk with me.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
Whenever I hear that line, just sounds very serious very
cliche you know like what it's like the exposition dump walk
with me i hate that line so much
someone will clean that up yeah she sounds like she's not
crazy honestly you're right there has been a lot of walking
what kind of sword is that It's new.
One of a kind.
My father gave it to me for Valkyrie training.
You're in Valkyrie training?
Got time to talk about it?
I was just heading to the Great Hall.
But if you need to go to work, grandfather's study is just
down those stairs.
Oh, no, no.
We can walk.
You said walk with me.
I'm ready to walk.
Let's go.
So how do you become a Valkyrie?
First I train till I'm the best I can be.
My new girlfriend.
And then I hope he and my dad can convince mom it's okay.
You know, my father and I, we encountered a whole bunch of
Valkyries.
What?
Where?
Promise to tell me everything.
I promise.
Mother, did you meet Loki?
Oh.
Now he's got you involved with this?
Involved with what?
I'm being friendly.
Isn't that diplomacy?
You understand who this is, right?
What his father did?
Why does he want him here?
Mom, come on.
You're embarrassing me.
Ah!
You're embarrassing me in front of you.
of the first boy i've ever i've ever met that's my age mom
oh my god mom right so did you want to look oh my god this
is actually like a teenager role play let's go wait where do
we go listen whatever grandfather is having you do remember
this is your chance to prove yourself that's all that some
of us want oh yeah I'll try to do some good don't run off I
don't want to get in trouble if you disappear oh my god gosh
please do not involve me in your pathetic attempts to
impress one another he does we're flirting guys I meant
she's interested I'm done Hi, Belkasey!
She's interested, guys!
We're in!
New dad, new girlfriend, new room, new armor, new me!
You said it!
You said it, so it's true!
Wait, I didn't want to go here.
What's over here?
That's my room.
Used to be Magnes.
Guess I'm moving up.
thought it's at least one fourth giant so like the giant
still have a chance I don't know to repopulate thank you for
the super chat banana thank you thank you I know me stood up
first alright I guess now we can go is that it guys can I
just go in we're moving up in the world and that's it to not
meet Odin wow look at that I met Odin and my it can only go
up now oh it's so good makes you really sick you love it
okay that's it all right let's go all right let's go meet
the all father now let's go talk to Odin
catch you later all right see you new girlfriend yeah do you
think she's I'm she's definitely into me guys yes do you see
me nodding and saying yes I understand I...
I...
Uh-huh.
Yes?
Yes, all right.
Mm-hmm.
You see, this is you not letting me talk.
No, Hugin, I don't need my ears cleaned.
I need you to stop croaking and and accept the answer you
know I'm about to give.
Oh?
Kind of magic.
Why is this sword tied to the wall?
Looking at this.
That old thing.
I've had that since.
Huh.
Who can remember?
Whoa.
You have a name?
Ingrid.
Ingrid?
Sure, why not?
And dad gave me a new sword consider it a perk of the job
thank you why did oh why did kratos not let me meet him come
on let's walk oh my god and i get a new sword guys she's
toky it's just that easy you're welcome immediately bought
because she it's just that easy oh my god new sword best dad
ever oh my god and i found money too it was just lying
they're not locked up in a chest next see they give us a
super chat they can thank you wait if odin is your new dad
doesn't that mean she's doing these everyone's got me all
wrong you think war drives me or power Nah, never have.
You know what drives me?
What I really want?
I want answers.
Same as you.
See, mortals have it easy.
When they push up against life's big questions, they can
look to us to give them meaning, divine comfort.
We both know that's a sham.
But when we have questions, why are we here to give meaning
to mortals while living without it ourselves?
No.
We're more than that.
and I found something that proves it.
What's wrong with that?
What is it?
Isn't it great to be a guy?
You feel it, don't you?
Feels like...
Knowledge.
Oh.
Truth.
All truth.
All the answers.
We could find out why we're here, learn how to change our
fates, stop Ragnarok for good, maybe.
save the people we love how I was a young God when I found
it touch it spent lifetimes studying it following every clue
down every dead end looking for finally unearthing this huh
see that she has the same mystical energy it opened a crack
can we just look I wouldn't recommend that.
Why not?
Oh.
He lost his eye from it.
What's the broken mask for?
Recognize any writing on it?
These aren't from the Nine Realms.
Obsidione Spica.
From smoldered earth and obsidian spark and a field of
battles never fought.
Are you certain?
He's literally the world's Google Translate.
Keep working with me.
He's Deep L.
You don't have to kill anyone.
You don't have to betray your father or yourself.
Come on.
I know you felt what I felt.
The answers are in there.
Let's get them.
I mean, you translated this language like it was nothing.
If I do help you, What's next?
Door!
Get down here!
All father.
Whoa!
What's next is chasing this down.
Take this.
And this stealthy side of beef.
And see where I've taken you.
I don't promise anything.
Nonsense.
Happy hunting.
And you.
Go easy on him.
You hear me?
Oh shit, is he my new sidekick?
Or I swear to God, if he doesn't fucking one-shot people,
I...
He's...
He's standbacking here.
He's definitely holding back.
There's no fucking way.
I swear to God.
Moose behind?
The rest of the mask is here?
It's where all father dropped us.
What do you think?
Just take that and do your damn job.
Oh my god, Thor and Loki!
the old gang is back where are we going how the fuck am i
supposed to oh my god whoa my father thinks that you know
what you're doing so do it oh yeah no he's definitely not
gonna equip the mass yeah he's not gonna try i can already
tell he's not he's not gonna try
weird well it seems like we go through this rock yeah he
does not care with those arms he does not care whoa
wait he's not even helping oh ingrid nice move what is he
he's just gonna watch oh i guess it'll just be two easy
you're right oh shit you can maybe help all right that makes
sense okay that's not fair
wait i gotta get this what the fuck okay no whatever nah
there we go you're right just be too easy if he helps oh my
god what the fuck Yeah.
Where are we supposed to head now?
A live tour reaction.
Yeah.
Right here.
Up there.
It looks like there might be a ledge we could reach.
If we...
Too slow.
Hey!
You can't just grab people like that?
No, what else are they gonna do?
Oh my god, he's actually helping guys!
Oh my god!
Wait, I don't have to do anything.
Look at him.
Oh, oh, okay.
Okay.
There.
There's things up there hitting us with fire.
Use your ball already.
Woo!
I'm doing my best, bro.
there you go all right nice oh my god this sword is crazy i
can't kratos do this oh my god he just fucking kicked them
and he's dead it took me like 20 shots and he just my blood
came in from your father for what happened to my son but i
haven't taken it from you what did i do yet what do you mean
yeah later Don't want to keep the all-father waiting.
I didn't do nothing.
Right.
Um, I didn't do anything.
It was all my dad's fault.
I was just a bystander.
Uh, Bray, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Now all we need is for them to pull the get help trick and
it'll be perfect.
Bray, thank you for the welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Anyway, there's something over here though.
I want to check here real quick.
Might be extra loot Yes, it's locked.
It's our way there.
Is that some kind of anvil?
I guess we can't get there yet
Yeah, it's locked.
Is there a way to get there?
I don't think so If it ain't there, let's keep moving come
on
like here i do your thing thor hey can you
what are you gonna do yeah that just imagine what it can do
to bone oh you want to talk no that's fine what about the
giants you killed they were my family gomwar ronan they were
your people too the giants were blight on the nine realms
and i in every single one of them oh yeah it is fine last
time father and i were here we beat every one of surter's
trials i think you could don't play me
why am i missing something
what the is that supposed to be
where's my sword Am I missing something?
Not yet?
Oh, is that for later?
For this one?
Oh, it's welcome to the Mena farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh, it's a secret for later.
Go grab that.
There's always golds in these pots.
How do I get over there?
Door?
We have to go there.
Any thought moment.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, okay, I see it.
Oh, he just jumped.
over you know you could you know help me you could you know
grab me too and take me to the other side but i guess he can
watch me climb this wall not too bad oh listen moody had
some problems but he was my son and the only reason you
aren't mush right now is because of that broken piece of
wood look clearly neither of us can do this mission alone
And I want to impress the Allfather just as much as you do.
You don't have to like me.
But we're going to have to trust each other.
Just a little bit.
Could be your new son.
Trust.
Or, you know, maybe son-in-law, you know?
Huh?
You know, you...
You know, your daughter sort of really likes me.
And then, you know, I could be your new son-in-law.
Yeah.
Don't bother getting up.
How come?
All right, go where sword is here That's right with the
power of the sword Oh shit, like what's the point?
I don't even have to do I get XP for the people he killed?
You're more than welcome to step it up.
This is me trusting you
Boom, that's right.
I bet Moni core didn't even do that That could be his
replacement system Sun, you know?
Alright, that's guys.
It's just this guy left.
There we go.
Plus one Sun.
Okay, I'm pretty sure I'm even a better Sun than Mori if you
think about it.
It's like this way.
Alright, it says this way, which means I gotta go this way.
There might be extra loot.
Give me a sec.
I gotta grab some extra loot.
I don't know.
I thought there might be bonus items there.
Could be a chest.
Wait, I don't grab the... Is that just HP?
Yeah, that's just HP.
Wait, what?
What?
Down here.
The mask is up.
Pulling this way.
We'll have to find some way down.
Sure thing.
I wasn't playing you, by the way.
The trials are fun.
Don't you ever have fun?
You're so different from your daughter.
She seemed...
Hey, come look at this.
Huh?
Never talk about my daughter again.
That was good thing he wasn't there when Haimedil...
caught on.
Oh my god.
Wait, Sir, there's shrine.
You didn't die over there, did you?
Here we gotta go.
Oh, reload.
I don't know if I shoot this if there's, like, money in
there.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
I was like, why are these random pots placed there?
My gamer senses were tingling.
No, but I was thinking Well, rest in peace, ankles.
Oh, my God, my poor ankles.
The trials are just past that cliff.
Might be something you and Thu can do together.
First, we deal with them.
Come on, Thor.
Just check them out.
What have you got to lose?
It's just like, I'm not here to fuck with you, kid.
I'm just going to get that mission done in and out.
don't worry door kick you get all of this look at him boom
instantly dead
like what's the point of having me here he can literally one
shot everybody oh my god oh my god can he one shot that
please Um, Thorin, Thorin, Thorin, there is a big guy over
here.
Another ogre?
Oh my god, there's so many ogres.
Thorin, Thorin, there is a giant ogre here!
Dooratra!
Can I get some help here?
His was short on time.
I'll humor you.
You just punched nothing.
He just punched nothing.
Oh my god, he's hitting everything but the fucking giant ass
ogre.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please, Thor.
Please!
He's just one hit!
Alright, nice.
Alright, I'll grab.
Nice.
That's where Guy did it.
Alright, I'll grab the archer.
You grab the other.
Alright, there we go.
I can help now.
Okay, I'm helping!
Alright.
Me too!
Boom!
See, I can help.
Thor save us.
The All Fathers waited hundreds of winters.
He can wait a little more.
It's fine.
Fine.
Stay right here.
Yes, sir.
Oh my god, I get to do the tries?
How's he doing?
Holy shit.
Oh!
I got the summon!
Wait, what is this?
Runic?
Summon Spectral Falcons that disrupt enemies and dives them
into the ground.
Oh man, wait.
Do I want...
I actually like the deer the most, though.
Not gonna lie.
Hopefully.
Come on!
Give me a challenge!
Alright.
I'll take it to that shrine.
Well...
Let me grab some extra...
extra money.
real quick money time is money all right how do i get to the
shrine while he's doing his little trials i should get to
that shrine all right all right artis give me a sec i want
to get that money as well all right here now that he's
distracted okay i'll upgrade my stuff now
you go yeah actually um no i don't have enough yeah i don't
have enough xp for that guys hey ingrid do you trust the ace
here i mean i know i can't trust them i just need them to
trust me but that's only gonna happen if they think i trust
them i knew it my father and i visited this place the last
time we were in moose behind feels like forever ago all
right oh we gotta go down here get free loot and down here
all right we're gonna head to the shrine before before thick
figures out that we didn't wait for him i know he seems very
scary
all right wait what oh okay my sword can't hit it okay i was
gonna say come on it's almost one more hit yeah good job
ingrid all right who is a good sword it's you it's you no no
no i have to try
oh no not to do my own fights What the fuck?
Hey, Gravota.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Okay.
My first, my other girlfriend.
Oh no.
Okay.
She doesn't know.
How is I supposed to know she would, she could leave?
You're here for Sorcerer's Marble.
Maybe.
You're out looking for more giant marbles.
You know what this looks like, right?
The life story of one of our people.
And also maybe a storage closet.
No.
This looks an awful lot like the fine destiny.
Look, we never said if we were official or not, guys.
If we were going steady.
So is it really my fault?
We never said if we were going steady or not.
It's not.
I thought it was a summertime thing.
But it's not.
I'm not working with them.
I would never tell them anything about iron.
would if that's what you're worried about.
And I'm definitely not serving him.
Prophecies words, not mine.
I've got a marble to find.
You're welcome to help if you want.
Fine.
But are you sure you're up for breaking the rules like this?
Damn, she wild.
Prophecies of you collecting any marbles.
Yeah, but she's her own person now.
And there's haven't been written, right?
Come on.
Shame.
Oh, hello there.
A sentient sword.
Huh.
Another marble.
Surders.
No soul in it, though.
So he's still out there somewhere.
Oh, that means he's alive, right?
A while back.
You talked about how the giants left.
You ever think about them?
All the time.
They're far from here.
Far from Odin and Thor.
But I wonder what lands they've gone to.
What seas they've crossed.
what I want to find them I'm gonna save my father and then
I'll find them it's starting oh who is that not surter
that's for sure look at all that frost hmm don't think I've
heard of her before and here comes surter wow this must have
been some fight yeah until it wasn't I saw they fell oh Oh,
no, no, look.
Oh, they fought together.
They're in love.
Looks like they even became friends.
Oh, more than friends.
Oh, yeah, just really, really good friends.
Just roommates, you know?
Is that what friends do?
Love caused them to combine into some kind of huge creature.
Oh, my God.
And then, Ragnarok destroys Asgard.
Right.
I saw that in Grower's shrine.
Oh.
They fused.
Oh, hey.
Remember the snake we put that soul in?
Can't really forget that.
Yeah, I was going to say, Steven Universe?
It's getting bigger.
Like, faster than normal figure.
Yeah, I had a feeling that would happen.
Huh.
I'm going to hang back here.
Don't want your friend to see a giant he missed.
Of course.
Just be careful.
You too, Loki.
I know, they like crystal fused.
They're like marble fusing.
Hey, Ingrid.
I think Thor died from...
You thought you could defeat the god of thunder?
Oh.
Yeah, no, I think he's very much alive.
He did a fusion dance.
Okay.
All right, let's go.
Got more HP that I don't need.
Of course.
I admit, that was fun.
There were mountains of corpses by the time I finished.
Cut down like wheat.
Yeah, I told you.
Great.
You want to help down here?
I'm not done.
If you beat all those trials.
Or did you just watch your father do it?
I'm meaty hey I was still learning oh my god what the fuck
that's fuck you are get out of here I'm so angry I'm trying
my best man the scores of these things I just killed it was
glorious yeah you're right maybe I should have watched why
the fuck I think you're right through She'd be faring better
than you, at least.
I'm trying my best!
Look, it's literally a water gets 20.
What do you want from me?
Bro, this stupid fucking archers.
Oh my god, that's right.
Get out of here.
I hate these guys the most.
There you go.
there's more oh my god i'm going wolf form fuck this oh my
god wait how much hp does this guy have i'm gonna grab him
again that's right i'm gonna fling him again you could have
done that at any time you seem to be handling yourself well
enough i was trusting you so where to let me check I think
it's this way.
Looks like we need to head through that gate.
Yeah, I was going to say that has a lot of HP.
Ain't that impressive?
Real god stuff.
You are a god.
You're damn right.
And so am I.
And it's like, yeah, but I can't believe this boy is in the
same.
It's in the same category as me.
I can't.
This is the spot.
in the lava i don't know oh shit oh there's the other mass
whoa oh what the fuck damn it some advice but maybe yeah i
was gonna say it wasn't thinking good it's better that way
all right let's get out of here oh just a little bird Loki
don't try to play me again you're an okay kid but you're
still a giant and a reveling oh he's like you might be a god
but we are not the same the riff got brighter look you did
it look one of these phrases is complete now we can read it
all but you can't translate it not yet see I got a little
theory I think if we can find the rest of this we can use it
to look into that without you know losing an eye or worse
look at this we make a good team don't we don't we make a
good damn team oh he's jealous uh you both behave out there
thor is jealous right now it was really great i learned a
lot from him he's like what about me your actual son really
now he's just like what teach the kid what about me father
nothing what could i possibly teach him exactly
ah i was wondering where that went actually i had a pretty
good idea change of heart i'm not really sure why i came
back it reminds me of the mask
I need you to know you can trust that mask was made by Loki
as well take this to the end I need to be able to trust you
and trust is earned I get it take this figure out the rest
of it if you're staying that is you're gonna tell me what
you're really looking for in there translate that and I'll
tell you everything and on that young man you can trust me
yeah yeah Jim Carrey one guys that's definitely the one I
was talking about I was actually thinking more so the I like
the animated series more always this hard on Thor seems like
you're mad at him or something I want to touch it what if I
touch it right now what if I touch it right now yeah the
movie that doesn't have the sequel yeah yeah definitely it's
not I definitely did not half the DVD of any sequel movies.
Oh.
Oh, these are cool.
That wood carving of the wolves.
Oh, chest.
Yeah, there was a cartoon.
Yeah, I guess we go up now.
Oh, wait.
There's more stuff.
I knew there was more stuff here.
More free stuff.
Nice.
I can't be there.
We just leave money lying here in the open.
Free money just for me.
The Jim Carrey movie was good.
It was.
I... I... Okay.
I... Personally... Okay.
I know I'm gonna be judged.
But I actually liked all iterations of the mask.
Like Son of a Mask.
The mask.
The animated shows.
I think they were all pretty good.
In my opinion.
I very much enjoyed all of them.
Okay.
uh hey sleep time yeah hello um i didn't meet any other
women except for you yeah i mean better than i would have
expected i guess is that the sword from grandfather's study
oh yeah her name's ingrid all right don't wrap me out ingrid
wow all father must really trust you well glad you survived
your first day hey me too tomorrow we talk about valk Oh,
definitely.
I'm so interested.
For sure.
Oh my god, we're like meant to be.
Anything else here?
Hey, I'm now.
Are you trying to make friends now?
What's wrong with that?
Well, I just aided the Our Father.
Yeah.
You said that makes us allies.
Yes, as long as you had no treacherous.
Interesting.
Huh?
what you're doing here anymore just so I'm just so in love
he always sees the best in people while all I see is what
people really are nobody ever says what they mean some lie
to the world some lie to themselves and don't even know it
and then there is you mm-hmm you don't know what you want
you You don't even know who you are.
I still have a couple years to figure that out.
I'm just a little boy.
I will be watching.
He said I still have time to figure out.
Fabs, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're not saying just saving money.
That's exactly.
Silly all-father leaving the money just lying around here.
I'm just giving them a safe place.
I'm just giving the money a safe place.
to be well this has been a weird day you know I'm like a
little personal bank for him anything new here oh nicely
equipped what needs work oh I can just upgrade this again
let's go missed dialogue it was some Asgardian woman talking
she doesn't even have a name so it's not really missed
dialogue
She didn't have a name, guys.
I don't think the dialogue would have been that important.
Wait, go to Thor's room?
Oh, I could have eavesdropped?
Oh, I didn't realize.
I thought you guys meant, like, the fucking random woman
that was talking at the dinner table.
Oh, I didn't even realize Thor's room was next to mine.
Oh, it's too late now.
Oops.
What were they gonna say anyway?
Huh?
My father.
I don't need him.
I have a new dad now.
He gave me a shining new.
He gave me a shining new sword.
Papa never gave me that sword before.
Yeah, that scene transition was really nice.
Good morning, brother.
No news, I'm afraid.
I have a plan.
Do you not?
What is it?
The Nords.
You found them once.
Could you do so again?
I could try, but I don't see how that would help.
They are the fates of these lands, are they not?
I would know what they know.
You may not find them cooperative.
As long as I find them.
Where do we search?
Midgard.
But if Atreus is an Asgard, there's no getting him back
without an army.
We should be raising one.
Yes, nothing like a catastrophic war to improve the
situation.
The boy seems quite capable, perhaps if you simply give him
some time.
You are not free of harm here.
You encouraged his foolishness.
You're not his father!
How dare you tell me what to do?
How to raise my son?
if Odin has stolen my son.
Do not doubt the lengths I will go to.
Your nature has always been clear, Kratos.
But you, Freya.
War is a first resort.
That's not the Freya I knew.
I hope the Norns can give you the counsel you need.
Perhaps mine is no longer of use here.
Tear, stop.
This is no time to define you.
ourselves further come sit please
you have been quiet frankly I'm surprised you of all people
would seek out fate yeah I thought you don't believe in that
shit your instincts haven't let us down so far let's find
the norms your tears stop being a drama queen who am I to
offer him counsel I only hoped to help the boy find his
answers and I failed What's my role in all this now?
Tear you're at the center of this you always have been
you're literally the one to start the Ragnarok shit He's
terrified of you.
I doubt that very much.
It's the truth and not just because of prophecies Literally
your purpose United the realms as you once did that is not
who I am anymore.
I know you feel that way now I've lost myself before more
than once but believe me there is something beyond that and
what is that purpose purpose is the path that leads you to
yourself so you would have me accept my fate lead your
armies into war secure your vengeance yes if securing our
justice is not your purpose then find another for your own
sake just find some sort of hobby man moping around is not
going to do us any justice it's not going to do anything
just find at least a hobby that's all we want from you tear
don't try to talk me into coming I mean I wasn't in their
tales of our fates it's everything I've walked in a job stop
eating if you're going to contribute to society Get a
fucking job and stop mooching off of our food.
And my house, by the way.
And my fucking house.
All right.
You did a job, you bum.
All right, don't we have any upgrades that we need to do?
No, I think we don't.
And we're fine.
Does it hurt?
Oh, this?
Only when I worry.
Um, technically it's my house because I literally funded...
Sindri's entire career.
So they might as well build this with my money.
So it is my house.
Hang on.
I got something for you.
Sindri.
Coming.
Before you go traipsing off into Gdawn, I thought you'd like
to have this back.
Oh, nice.
My shield.
Well, don't go getting too cheery about it.
But you're welcome.
My money literally built this place.
Shall we go?
Stop being your money when you gave it to him.
I loaned it to them.
I said that you may have consequences to look for.
I lended it to them.
Hello?
Squirrel.
Ah, Master Kratos, my apologies.
Madam Nithogue's disappearance weighs heavily on my mind.
She a friend of yours?
Oh, the worm.
Yeah, what happened to the worm?
Tenant of the tree.
She was here even before I arrived, and that was ages ago.
To even think something could keep her away from her babies.
Terrible, just terrible.
Was that it?
Okay.
Alright, we gotta go to Midgard!
What's over here?
Eyes of Odin, a Crucible.
Stuff that don't matter.
still haven't unlocked three of these worlds yet.
There's still three more places we have to unlock.
Oh, wait, I killed the worm.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I just remembered I killed the worm.
Oh, that's awkward.
That is not the only answer.
All right, well, they don't know.
They don't know.
The babies don't know any also, so they won't get revenge.
near the frozen lake i stashed one for spell crafting but we
may yeah i just remember it but the worm we killed with fear
they really don't want to be found well at least things will
be difficult for a
change i want to access this next area your sled and head to
the lake all right oh is this save here where is the saving
here manual save alright I'm gonna call it here I've been
yawning a lot I'm getting really easy and tired I'm gonna
call it here guys oh I was yawning a lot in the last hour
because I was getting really tired I think I just didn't get
a lot of sleep today um I had like I was dreaming a lot last
night and I was just like oh and that like took up a lot of
my brain power uh but it's been fun so far nice to get back
into god of war again um i wanted to do two streams next
week for god of war but next week is so packed um i can't
really say exactly what the stream plans are for next week
but when it's announced you guys will know like that's all i
can say when it's announced you guys will know so i know we
have our tournament is also is a term no not next there's
like it's just a lot it's a lot of stuff it's a lot of stuff
going on in february is my hell month that's why i've been
like extra tired as well because there's a lot of stuff
going on behind the scene so like i don't even know if i can
fit in two god of war streams i can definitely try and fit
in one god of war but not two um but anyway guys thank you
all for watching it's nice to be back to god of war um i am
just take a nap after like take a nap after this but as
always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around and get that blood flowing and if you do stuff for me
head to bed cause you deserve it i hope to see you guys at
the anniversary stream on saturday i'm so hyped for it i
can't wait to show you all the stuff i've planned out for uh
on for the saturday stream i'm gonna rate i'm gonna go rate
the waiting room even though i know it's like there's still
a few more days left but ah can't wait i can't wait hey guys
I'll see you guys tomorrow everybody.
I think tomorrow's stream is Neo.
I know I didn't play one and two but I just couldn't wait.
I really want to check out Neo 3.
So we're going to be playing the launch date of Neo 3.
I'm super excited because it's like it's it could be really
really good or it might be ass.
Who knows?
We're going to find out tomorrow.
Anyway guys, I'll see you guys later everybody.
Bye everyone.
Bye.